Général Vincent Desportes, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. On vous reçoit dans le
cadre de votre activité passée,
présente, future. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Donc je
Vincent, je suis euh effectivement
général et toujours général puisque dans
euh l'armée française, on on reste
général jusqu'à au moins l'âge de 67
ans. Donc je suis en 2e session des
officiers généraux. J'ai eu une carrière
assez longue puisque j'ai été soldat
pendant pendant 38 ans. Euh assez varié
euh également parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup de métiers. J'ai été euh
diplomate, j'ai été forcément dans la
formation, j'ai été dans la dans le
commandement, j'ai été un peu dans les
opérations. Euh voilà et puis j'ai eu la
chance de terminer ma carrière dans deux
postes qui étaient passionnants. Le
premier euh ou l'avant-dernier poste,
c'est le poste chef de du centre de
doctrine d'emploi des forces. À un
moment où il fallait euh
retravailler la pensée militaire
française parce qu'on sortait de la
guerre froide avec une pensée qui
n'avait pas beaucoup évolué. et on
tombait dans des des conflits nouveaux
et il fallait vraiment réfléchir à la
pensée qui pouvait soutenir nos actions,
la doctrine. Et donc j'ai fait ça avec
une une nom important d'officiers
intelligents et donc je crois qu'on a
fait avancer la pensée militaire et j'ai
eu la chance ensuite de terminer ma
carrière d'active en commandant l'école
de guerre qui s'appelait avant le
collège intéarmé de défense et j'ai eu
le grand plaisir après m'être battu
pendant 2 ans pour que le nom change de
voir effectivement quelques jours après
mon départ cette école prendre enfin le
nom qu'elle méritait c'est-à-dire
l'école de guerre c'est-à-dire qu'enfin
Enfin, on sortait de cette fausse
interprétation du monde née en 1989 qui
nous disait que la guerre avait disparu
et que l'école de guerre n'était pas
faite pour apprendre à faire la guerre.
Et bien si, la guerre n'a pas disparu,
on le sait. Et donc, j'étais très
heureux pendant 2 ans de former les
meilleurs de nos officiers de marine, de
l'armée de l'air, de la gendarmerie et
de l'armée terre à leur future
responsabilité.
On commence les hostilités.
J'adore
le quel quels sont les conflits qui
risquent de nous tomber dessus à court
terme, c'est-à-dire dans les moins moins
de 5 ans ? Est-ce que on peut avoir un
conflit ouvert avec la Russie ? Est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un conflit ouvert avec
les États-Unis si c'est si ça n'est pas
déjà le cas entre la guerre économique
que nous sommbissons de point de plein
fouet ? Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Alors je je sais pas de quoi vous me
parlez. Les les conflits, il y en a en
permanence. Est-ce qu'on parle de de
conflits armés ou de conflits d'autres
nature ? conflit armé avec la Russie,
avec les États-Unis. Je je je bon alors
je je crois que la première chose à
faire, la première chose à penser parmi
tous ceux qui nous nous écoutent et nous
regardent, c'est que la guerre est
revenue, hein. Les les Européens ont
pensé pendant 70 ans 80 ans presque que
la guerre avait disparu et on a cru à
tort que parce que nous avions tué
effectivement la guerre en Europe, nous
l'avions tué dans le monde et les pays
européens ont pris une attitude de pays
qui pensaient que la guerre avait
disparu et on voit que la guerre
revient, qu'elle n'a jamais été aussi
proche et que les champs de brève sont
en train d'entourer l'Europe. Et on se
rappelle évidemment le mot de Trotky qui
nous disait "Si vous ne vous occupez pas
de la guerre et c'est ce que nous avons
fait pendant très longtemps, la guerre
s'occupera de vous. Voilà où nous en
sommes aujourd'hui. Je ne sais pas quels
seront les conflits de demain, mais ce
que ce que je sais, c'est que la guerre
et là, c'est éternelle puisqu'elle
existe depuis l'homme que l'homme est
l'homme. Et la guerre est là, elle
reviendra, elle est déjà là puisque
l'armée française est en guerre
aujourd'hui avec 30000 marins, soldats
et aviateurs en position opérationnelle
avec des blessés chaque semaine. Hélas
parfois des morts. En 2018, nous avons
eu plusieurs morts par fait de guerre.
Donc la guerre est là, elle reviendra.
Quelle forme prendra-t-elle demain ?
C'est c'est très difficile de le dire.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que la guerre a le
comme habitude d'échapper à ces modèles.
Ce qui fait qu'on reproche souvent aux
militaires de se préparer pour la guerre
d'hier. Et bien le fait c'est que la
guerre échappant toujours à ces modèles,
se présentant toujours sous une nouvelle
forme. Claudovit disait que la guerre
était un caméléon, c'est-à-dire qu'elle
évolue en permanence. Il est extrêmement
difficile de prévoir la guerre de
demain. Ce qu'on sait probablement,
on sait plusieurs choses. On sait
d'abord que la guerre euh se saisit de
tous les espaces que l'homme conquier.
L'homme a conquis la terre, évidemment,
était sur terre, la guerre a commencé
sur terre. Ensuite, l'homme a a conquis
la mer, la guerre est venue sur mer.
Ensuite, au début du 20e siècle, l'air,
ensuite l'espace et maintenant le
cyberespace. Je ne sais pas quel espace
l'homme va conquérir, mais il en
conquéra d'autres puisque d'autres
espaces vont apparaître et ce qui est
sûr, c'est que la guerre y viendra.
Quelle sera sa forme, je ne sais pas.
Quel sera notre adversaire ? Je ne sais
pas. Mais ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'une
nation qui ne prétend que la guerre a
disparu, une nation qui ne se défend pas
et bien va subir des coups terribles et
finira par disparaître. Il est donc dans
la mission des nations et des États de
préparer la défense euh de leur de leur
concitoyens, de leur état. Face à des
guerres qu'on ne connaît pas, qui
viendront tôt ou tard et c'est bien ça
la difficulté.
On en est où avec l'OTAN ?
On en est où avec l'OTAN ? Alors euh
[grognement] je sais pas de quoi de quoi
vous vous vous voulez parler.
Est-ce que on a réintégré le Conseil de
l'OTAN ? Est-ce qu'on va ressortir ?
Est-ce que l'armée européenne va
remplacer l'OTAN ? Est-ce que l'OTAN n'a
pas une utilité d'encercler la Russie ?
Est-ce que l'OTAN a quand même sa sa
légitimité ? Est-ce que l'OTAN a perdu
sa légitimité ? Alors, je je si vous
permettez, je crois qu'il faut euh
revenir à à un problème fondamental que
le que beaucoup de Français ont pas
compris et énormément d'Européens,
encore plus d'Européens n'ont pas
compris ce problème qui est directement
lié à l'OTAN, c'est l'inévitable
découplage de l'Europe et des
États-Unis. Nous n'en n'avons pas
conscience parce que nous vivons depuis
des décennies avec cette idée qu'il y a
un lien extrêmement fort entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe et que la preuve
en est, c'est que c'est les Américains
sont venus mourir pour nous en 1917 et
en 1943 en Europe, quelque chose comme
ça. Puis 44, 45 et cetera, on le sait
bien. Et donc on a cette idée que quoi
qu'il arrive, le soldat Ryan reviendra
et que quand on s'appuie sa sa défense
sur l'Amérique, on a raison. on joue le
bon cheval et bien force est de
constater que c'est une grave erreur.
C'est une grave erreur parce que le
découplage entre l'Europe et l'Amérique
l'Amérique est inscrit dans la ligne du
temps. On ne pourra pas y échapper pour
un certain nombre de raisons que je suis
prêt à vous à à vous expliquer. La la la
il y a deux deux raisons essentielles.
On on assiste clairement à une dérive de
l' de l'Amérique vers son Ouest, vers le
Pacifique et vers et vers l'Asie.
Pourquoi ? D'abord, pourquoi est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a ce lien si fort
entre la Pourquoi avions-nous ce lien si
fort entre les États-Unis et l'Europe ?
Pour deux raisons. La première, c'est
une affaire bassement commerciale. Une
affaire bassement commerciale. Pendant
très longtemps, l'Europe a été la
première zone de chalondise des
États-Unis. Et si l'Amérique n'est plus
capable de commercer avec l'Europe, et
bien le le commerce américain, la
qualité de vie américaine s'effondre. Et
donc une des deux raisons fondamentales
qui ont poussé les Américains à revenir
en 1917 en 1943 en Europe, c'est bien la
nécessité de remettre de l'ordre dans
leur marché parce qu'on ne pouvait plus
faire de commerce. Ça n'est pas la seule
raison hein, il y a une raison qui pose
sur les valeurs, mais c'est une raison
forte. Or là les choses changent. les
choses changent puisque alors que
l'Europe était le principal marché
américain, il est encore mais les choses
change. La tendance est très forte.
Bientôt la part des échanges entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe sera inférieure à
la part des échanges entre l'Amérique et
la Chine et cetera. Et donc on va les
Américains n'auront plus cet intérêt
mercantile commercial de revenir mettre
de l'ordre dans leur zone de chandi. Ça
c'est la première raison. La deuxième
raison, c'est que pourquoi est-ce que
les Américains sont revenus nous
défendre, c'est parce qu'ils sentaient
qu'il y avait quelque chose de très
fort, de charnel entre l'Amérique et
l'Europe. Et ça, c'est en train de
changer. Pourquoi ? Quand les Américains
reviennent chez nous en 43 au 44, il y a
chacun a un grand-père, un oncle, un
arrière- grand-père qui est en Europe.
On sait ce que c'est, on y a vécu.
C'est-à-dire que l'Europe n'est pas la
mère patrie, mais c'est la grand-mère
patrie et on vient rétablir, on vient
défendre ceci. Aujourd'hui, les choses
ont changé. Il y a une vérité
démographique. Et quelle est la vérité
démographique ? La vérité démographique
est qu'en 2040, en 2040, la majorité des
Américains ne seront plus d'origine
européenne. Ils seront d'origine
africaine, ils seront d'origine
hispanique, Amérique latine ou d'origine
asiatique. Et d'ailleurs, la preuve en
est. Monsieur Obama, remarquable
président et un premier aperçu. Obama,
monsieur Obama ne comprendait pas
extrêmement bien l'Europe parce qu'il
n'avait pas de lien charnel et c'est un
premier un premier élément et ça va
forcément continuer. Regardez et la la
l'évolution de la chambre des
représentants depuis notre les élections
du 4 novembre et bien elle s'est bruni.
Elle s'est brun. On on ça n'est pas mal,
c'est juste comme ça. Et en 2040 et bien
les Waspes hein, les WASP les les les
Anglo-Saxons protestants attachés à
l'Europe seront en grande minorité et
ils n'auront plus la capacité d'aller
défendre l'Europe qui les intéressera
plus. Donc en 2040 et bien ce lien sera
rompu et quelque part vers 2040
peut-être 2045 peut-être 2050 le dernier
bateau américain quittera le port
d'envers ou le le port de Brest avec le
dernier soldat américain et il repartira
vers Baltimore. Et là nous européens
nous serons là. Et si avant cette
échéance, nous n'avons pas bâti d'une
part notre autonomie stratégique et nous
en sommes loin et d'autre part notre
autonomie en terme de défense et bien
nous serons mal. Et donc il faut
absolument bâtir cette autonomie en
terme de défense et en terme
stratégique. Et c'est là où intervient
l'OTAN. Et quand vous regardez l'OTAN,
vous apercevez qu'aujourd'hui l'OTAN
représente un danger pour l'Europe. Un
danger pour l'Europe pour de multiples
raisons. Pour de multiples raisons. La
première est que l'OTAN est un outil à
déresponsabiliser
hein. La majorité des gouvernements, pas
le gouvernement français mais la
majorité des gouvernements européens
sont bien trop heureux de pouvoir dire à
leurs concitoyens ne vous en faites pas
les enfants, vous êtes protégés par par
l'oncle sable, donc on n'est pas obligé
de faire des dépenses de défense très
importantes. De toute façon, on sera
protégé et donc on peut engager le
l'argent public dans d'autres domaines
que dans le domaine de la défense. Et
donc aujourd'hui la défense européenne,
même si elle additionnait l'ensemble des
défenses, serait quand même très peu de
choses par rapport à nos besoins. Donc
c'est un outil de déresponsabilisation.
C'est aussi, je pense, un outil qui crée
des tensions en Europe. L'OTAN aurait dû
mourir en 1989. Bon, il a perduré.
Alors, vous savez comme moi que l'OTAN
est allé se chercher de nouvelles
missions en Afghanistan et ça n'a pas
été particulièrement brillant. Et donc
on a fini avec cette affaire-là et donc
l'autom a dit non non c'est fini ces
opérations là nous nous sommes ici pour
défendre l'Europe article 5 et cetera et
il a bien fallu se trouver un un un
ennemi et qu'il y ait de nouvelles
tensions et cetera et donc l'OTAN est
évidemment pour quelque chose dans la
montée des tensions entre la l'Europe
d'un côté et la Russie d'autre part.
Écoutez, les discours du secrétaire
général de l'OTAN, et bien il représente
son institution et au lieu d'aller
chercher l'apaisement, on est plutôt
dans une démarche de tension
d'antagonisme qui est évidemment tout à
fait tout à fait dangereuse. L'OTAN est
une institution qui a échappé à la mort
de peu au début des années 90 et
aujourd'hui elle s'est cherché une
mission et puis elle cherche à vivre. Il
faut bien comprendre que l'OTAN est une
institution et que toutes les
institutions du monde ont comme première
vocation de chercher à perdurer dans
leur être. Et donc il faut il faut avoir
des missions et cetera. Les armées des
pays européens, pas la France mais dans
la plupart des armées et ben on a besoin
de l'OTAN pour bah avoir des étoiles,
pour croître, pour avoir des carrières.
Donc on a l'OTAN aujourd'hui représente
beaucoup d'intérêts individuels et je ne
suis pas sûr que l'OTAN représente les
intérêts collectif. Donc je pense
aujourd'hui que l'OTAN est une menace. À
quoi sert l'OTAN aujourd'hui ? L'OTAN
est un outil est un outil d'abord chacun
c'est mercantil he c'est-à-dire que
quand monsieur Trump dit vous devez
dépenser 2 % de votre PIB dans votre
défense c'est pour acheter du matériel
autant et ça marche. garder nos
camarades, nos amis belges hein qui nous
ont fait quand même la traîtrise hein
d'aller acheter des F35 hein alors que
eux sont naturellement quand même parmi
les plus européens et ils ont le
sentiment européen mais quand même ils
misent à droite et à gauche et ils vont
acheter ils vont acheter américains.
Donc monsieur Trump est d'abord un
commerçant, un homme d'affaires et
l'OTAN pour lui est une très bonne façon
de faire vivre, de trouver des marchés
pour son industrie de défense. Voilà une
bonne raison de de faire de faire
perdurer l'OTAN. Alors alors dans cette
dans cette dans cette affaire là, est-ce
que il faut tuer l'OTAN ? Bon, faut pas
tuer l'autant, mais il faut au minimum
avoir un pilier européen qui puisse
permettre de parler d'égal à égal avec
les États-Unis, ce qui n'est pas vrai.
La plus grande crainte des Américains,
c'est d'avoir un cocus européen au
centre de l'Europe et donc de parler
d'égal à égal. C'est c'est la c'est la
grande antise des Américains. Et donc
dans l'OTAN, on fait du bilatéral.
l'Europe n'existe pas et dans leurs
opérations, les Américains font très
attention à ne pas faire vivre l'Europe.
Quelle est la plus grande opération
européenne depuis le la fin de la guerre
froide ou même la deuxème guerre
mondiale ? C'est notre opération en
Afghanistan. L'Europe a 30000 soldats
déployés pendant plus de 10 ans. Voilà
une sacrée opération. Mais en aucun cas,
ce ne fut une opération européenne. Les
Américains y ont bien veillé. On aurait
pu avoir une répartition de l'espace
qu'aurait confié à l'Europe une partie
de l'Afghanistan et puis aux Américains
une autre partie et l'Europe aurait
existé. Elle n'a pas existé parce que
les Américains ont fait très attention à
répartir les contingents les contingents
américains par nation en leur donnant
des chefs américains. Ce et donc chaque
nation était là combattait. La France a
combattu de manière tout à fait
courageuse mais l'Europe n'a pas existé.
Et donc je crois qu'il faut comprendre
que l'OTAN est un des outils de
domination de l'Europe et les États-Unis
d'ailleurs ne s'en ne s'en cachez pas.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire. J'ai
j'ai eu la chance de servir la France
aux États-Unis et en particulier d'avoir
une petite partie de ma carrière en tant
que diplomate.
Vos études aussi ? Vous oui, j'ai fait
j'ai fait j'ai eu la chance de faire
l'école des généraux américains à
Carlaï, ce qui était une très très bonne
façon d'essayer de comprendre euh ce que
ce qu'est l'Amérique et ce que sont nos
Amériens qui ont des état de qualité par
ailleurs et loin de moi le l'idée de
dire le contraire. Mais donc j'étais euh
il se trouve aux États-Unis
euh au début des années 2000,
c'est-à-dire à à à Washington à
l'ambassade. Donc je travaillais
quasiment tous les jours au département
d'État ou euh au département d'État ou
ou au Pentagone. He
c'était à l'époque de Andréan. C'était à
l'époque, non, c'était après c'était le
monsieur l'ambassadeur était
l'ambassadeur bouge de bugon de l'estan
et ensuite j'ai eu la chance de servir
sous les sous sur la direction de
l'ambassadeur de l'ambassadeur Lévit. Et
donc on est on est là et les Américains
ont beaucoup de qualité et parmi
celles-ci ils ont la franchise, ils
parlent peut-être plus que leur camarade
d'anglais parfois et donc à un moment
donné quand qu' bouche au arrive aux
affaires. Donc quelque chose comme le 20
janvier 2001 si je ne m'abuse puisque
c'est toujours le 20 janvier, on peut
pas trop se tromper aux États-Unis. Le
20 janvier une des premières questions
qu'il pose c'est à quoi sert le temps ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc ? Je
mets de l'argent dedans. Est-ce que
c'est utile ? et il pose la question
rive droite du potomac au Pentagone et
puis il a ri pos rive gauche au
département d'État ministère des
affaires étrangères américains. Et la
réponse du Pentagone est immédiate mais
l'OTAN ne sert à rien. D'ailleurs, nous
savez bien monsieur le président que
nous-mêmes militaire américain nous
sommes pasiens. Nous sommes les moins
otaniens de l'OTAN. Donc non, il faut
arrêter cette affaire là, c'est de
l'argent perdu. Alors la question est
évidemment posée au département d'État
et le département d'État dit exactement
l'inverse. Il non monsieur le président
surtout pas. Il faut conserver l'OTAN.
L'OTAN est le meilleur outil de maîtrise
de l'Europe et dans le combat c'est on
le sait bien c'est le département d'État
qui va l'emporter et l'OTAN survit non
pas comme un outil militaire rejeté par
le Pentagone mais comme un outil
diplomatique de maîtrise de l'Europe et
le jeu se met en place. Quel est le
problème ? Donc l'Europe pour les
Américains doit être en perpétuel
devenir une Europe advenue est une
Europe qui est dangereuse parce qu'elle
peut parler d'égal à égal et donc
l'Europe ne doit jamais advenir. Donc il
faut une Europe en perpétuel devenir et
dans le son se perd un peu dans
l'espace. Alors quelle meilleure manière
que de l'élargir ? Il faut que l'Europe
s'élargisse. Quel est le meilleur moyen
de le faire ? Très simple élargissons
l'utant et vous verrez messieurs que
l'Europe va s'élargir derrière. Et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé. Et il
serait intéressant que ceux qui nous
écoutent aillent voir les calendriers
d'évolution de d'agrandissement de
l'OTAN et les calendriers
d'élargissement de l'Europe. Vous
apercevez que l'Europe s'élargit au
rythme de l'OTAN un peu derrière.
C'est-à-dire qu'un des effets de
l'élargissement de l'OTAN va être la
comment dirait-on ? Comment dit-on ? La
dissipation, c'est pas exactement le bon
terme, de l'Europe dans l'espace.
L'Europe qui devait être à 12 ou à 15,
peut-être en 2002 à vérifier hein, elle
va passer à 26, à 27, à 28 et cetera. Et
donc elle est inaudible, elle ne parle
pas, elle ne prend plus de décision. Les
dates sont claires. Prenons le cas de la
Pologne, c'est c'est le c'est le seul,
je crois, que j'ai que j'ai en tête. La
Pologne rentre dans le temps en en 2009
et bien quelques années après, elle va
rentrer dans l'Europe et pour tous les
pays, ça va être comme ça. D'accord ?
Donc, j'avance l'OTAN, j'avance l'Europe
et au bout d'un moment l'Europe est
dissoute. Il y a qu'un truc quand même
que les Européens
ont refusé ont refusé, c'est d'admettre
la Turquie dans l'Europe. Rappelez-vous
les pressions de monsieur Obama pour que
la pour que la l'Europe qui est
otanienne. Et pourquoi elle est
otanienne ? Pourquoi pas l'Europe et
cetera ? Et là, les les Européens ont
senti quand même qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui qui n'allait pas, qu'on allait
un tout petit peu trop loin. Et puis les
événements qui ont suivi la montée de de
Daesh à partir de 2014 nous ont bien
montré que non, la Turquie ne pouvait
pas faire partie de l'Europe. Mais on
voit bien cette volonté permanente,
quels que soient les moyens de de faire
en sorte que l'Europe ne gêne pas le jeu
le jeu le jeu de l'Amérique, que
l'Europe reste un vasal utile mais un
vassal capable d'apporter les moyens
mais dont la voie ne porte pas. ce qui
explique que et bien on est contre
l'Europe de la défense forcément parce
que depuis que le monde des mondees
depuis que le monde des monde on écoute
la voix que si elle porte l'épée. C'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui la
France a un rôle beaucoup plus important
que l'Europe au plan international parce
que le parce que la France a une épée
qui est aiguisée, qui est
opérationnelle, qui sait faire des
choses. Et donc quand monsieur Macron ou
monsieur ou monsieur
euh Hollande ou monsieur Sarkozy dit "Je
vais faire quelque chose", on le fait
intelligemment ou pas hein, c'est pas le
point. Mais en Libye
revenir intelligemment en Libye
comment
on va y revenir ? Oui, je dis pas mais
enfin ce que je veux dire c'est que
quand la France veut elle peut délivrer.
L'Europe ne peut pas délivrer parce
qu'elle n'a pas des pays. Donc sa voix
n'est pas entendu. Donc la défense
européenne va contre les intérêts
d'hégémonie occidentale des États-Unis.
Ce qui est grave parce que tout ça irait
bien si les intérêts américains et les
intérêts européens étaient les mêmes.
Or, ils ne sont pas les mêmes. On le
voit tous les jours dans les problèmes
économiques, dans les problèmes
stratégiques. Revenons à notre soldat
Ryan qui quitte le dernier le territoire
européen dans le dernier bateau qui
repart vers Baltimor. Qu'est-ce qui nous
reste ? Il nous reste la Russie. Nous
nous sommes condamnés à vivre dans ce
dans ce continent euh euroreasiatique
euh européen et Russie. Et à la fin, il
faudrait bien qu'on arrive à à vivre
ensemble dans cette affaire-là. Et donc
la la montée des tensions qui correspond
à des intérêts américains ne correspond
sûrement pas à des intérêts à long terme
de l'Europe. Et là et là je crois qu'il
faut se rappeler de l'après-gerre ou des
après-guerres. Nous avons réussi un
après-guerre mondiale et nous avons
totalement raté un autre après-guerre
mondiale. L'après-gerre qui a été ratée,
chacun le sait, c'est l'après-première
guerre mondiale avec le traité de
Versailles qui a conduit, qui a euh qui
n'a pas permis de d'installer la paix
durablement parce qu'elle a écrasé le
vaincu et n'a pas compris qu'on devrait
vivre qu'on devrait vivre ensemble. Et
chacun sait et chacun de vos auditeurs
le sait. C'est bien dans le traité de
Versailles qu'on va trouver les germes
des tensions des années 20 et des années
30 et puis l'explosion de cette terrible
2e guerre mondiale et de ces 60 millions
de morts. Alors la 2e guerre mondiale là
on a compris les Américains ont compris
que le point était de faire tomber des
tensions et de relever l'adversaire et
de pour de le réinsérer dans le jeu du
dialogue des nations. Et ça a été le
plan Marshall comme comme vous le savez.
Et grâce au plan Marchal et ben on a
réussi cette après-guerre qui nous ont
donné et merci à à à nos pères et à nos
grands-pères qui nous ont donné 70 ans
75 ans de paix. Une période incroyable
de paix pour l'Europe. Qu'est-ce qu'on a
raté ? On arrêtait l'après- 3è guerre
mondiale. Si on considère que la guerre
froide était une possible guerre
mondiale mais froide, nous l'avons
totalement raté alors qu'il fallait
faire de la Russie un partenaire pour
que justement le risque ne guerre ne
monte pas. Comme en 1919 au traité de
Versailles, on a eu des sortes de
traités inégaux hein et qui d'ailleurs
on a gardé l' temp le pact de Varsovie a
été dissous. On n'a pas créé les
conditions de la paix future. Ma
crainte. Ma crainte est que et bien les
conséquences de cette paix ratée soit
aussi euh aussi néfastes que les
conséquences de la paix ratée au début
des années 20.
Vous parlez des États-Unis, vous parlez
de la Russie, on va commencer par les
États-Unis. Est-ce qu'on peut réellement
considérer les États-Unis comme nos
alliés quand on voit les écoutes de la
NSA, nos différents présidents écoutés
par la NSA ? Quand on voit Alstom, euh
quand on voit euh la projection du droit
américain, euh quand on utilise le
dollar, la la capacité de des États-Unis
à bloquer les ventes d'armes françaises
parce que il y a une puce qui se balade
euh dans un des dans dans un produit euh
français. Euh est-ce qu'on peut
réellement considérer les Américains
comme nos alliés ?
Bon, d'une part,
c'est pas une alliance de façade alors
que derrière pour parler trivialement,
ils nous mettent régulièrement des
couteaux dans le dos. Bon, d'une part,
vous venez de répondre à la question et
d'autre part moi j'ai répondu avant et
et c'est je crois que il faut il faut il
faut se se savoir que et comme le disait
pour justement de Gaul, les les nations
n'ont pas d'amis, elles n'ont que des
intérêts. Alors quand les intérêts sont
un peu mélangés avec les valeurs, avec
l'histoire, entre le lien et cetera, et
bien on arrive à à considérer à juste
titre que les États-Unis sont un allié.
Et heureusement que les alliés que les
Américains sont sont venus nous délivrer
de la de la menace allemande en en 17 et
et en 44 en en Normandie. Ben
aujourd'hui, on voit que les intérêts
américains, c'est ce que je disais, sont
de plus en plus divergents. Ils sont de
plus en plus divergents et aujourd'hui
c'est particulièrement net l'affaire de
l'ext de l'extrat de territorialité, du
droit américain et cetera. On voit bien
que les intérêts sont pas les mêmes. Et
donc, il est temps de de trouver nous
notre autonomie stratégique. Et les les
Américains ont une attitude de fort.
Quand je suis fort, j'ai une petite
tendance à écraser le faible. Et nous,
nous sommes fait nous sommes faibles
parce que on a tellement besoin de cette
défense-là qu'on n'est pas capable
d'opposer un front uni. Pour que les
États-Unis redeviennent un allié fiable,
il faut que nous soyons forts, que nous
soyons autonomes, que nous ayons une
capacité de défense et que nous ne
soyons pas liés. Aujourd'hui, nous
sommes dépendants en terme de défense
des États-Unis.
Comment [raclement de gorge] terme de
renseignement ? En terme de
renseignement, nous sommes Oui, nous
sommes nous sommes je sais pas si nous
sommes dépendants hein. Euh un des une
des grandes qualités des des grands pays
euh des grands pays européens, c'est
qu'ils ont extrêmement renseignements
qui sont fiables et en particulier,
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites, que
c'est bien parce que en 1990,
le gouvernement français s'est rendu
compte que les Américains le roul dans
les dans roulaient le gouvernement
français dans dans la salade, en
particulier dans la description qu'il
faisait du dispositif iraquien et
cetera. On voyait qu'on vendait à la
France des choses qui étaient fausses.
On avait suffisamment de moyens de
renseignement et d'intelligence
situation pour comprendre qu'on nous
entumer. Et donc c'est à ce moment-là
que par exemple je parlant de la France
euh s'est créé la direction du
renseignement militaire et qu'on s'est
effectivement organisé pour avoir une
autonomie de décision. Donc euh pour
avoir un jugement personnel pour avoir
un jugement personnel et donc et
aujourd'hui on a une capacité de
renseignement qui qui est important mais
on a bien vu que quand on l'avait pas
les Américains cherchaient à nous vendre
des choses qui étaient fausses. On le
sait ça c'est c'est absolument factuel
et donc il est très important d'avoir
notre service des services de
renseignement qui nous donnent
l'autonomie mais nous ne l'avons pas.
Nous ne l'avons pas. Si je prends
l'exemple très concret de notre guerre
au Sahel, puisque nous sommes bien en
guerre au Sahel avec 5000 soldats en
guerre, des blessés, des morts et
cetera, et bien nous avons besoin du
renseignement américain parce que nous
n'avons pas les nous n'avons pas les
moyens hein de d'établir le
renseignement dont dont nous avons
besoin. Nous avons été obligés de louer
des drones par exemple. Notre
effectivement notre renseignement
satellitaire n'est pas à la hauteur de
ce qu'il devrait être et cetera.
Pourquoi c'est comme ça ? Pourquoi c'est
comme ça ? Parce que ça avait du sens
pendant l'ère froide tout ça hein.
Effectivement l'Amérique était le
l'armée dominante et puis il y avait une
espèce de partage des tâches et les le
renseignement stratégique était quand
même essentiellement américain. Nous on
faisait du renjeignement tactique
encore. On était pas très bon croyez
croyez-moi. J'y étais. On on était pas
très bon. On avait pas beaucoup de
moyens. Et puis euh ben les choses ont
évolué et on n'a pas su se doter parce
qu'on croyait toujours en l'Amérique des
moyens qui nous auraient doté de
l'autonomie euh stratégique, l'autonomie
de décision, l'autonomie de l'autonomie
de jugement. Et ça c'est vrai en terme
de renseignement, c'est vrai aussi, on
le sait en terme de
par exemple de de logistique de
logistique et de transport de transport
stratégique. Aujourd'hui, nous serions
clairement incapables de conduire notre
opération au Sahel si nous ne disposions
pas de l'aide américaine. nous aurions
été totalement incapable de conduire
l'opération Servale comme nous l'avons
conduite en 2013 sans l'aide massive
américaine. Ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous ne l'aurions pas fait mais au lieu
de nous projeter rapidement et en en 3 4
semaines d'avoir réglé le problème
tactique qui nous était posé et ben on
aurait mis de 3 4 mois pour se déployer
et cetera. Donc les les choses auraient
été complètement différentes. Ce qui
veut dire aujourd'hui et c'est bien un
vrai problème et c'est pour ça qu'il est
temps que l'Europe enfin se donne se
dote des moyens nécessaires à son
autonomie. C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons réellement conduire que
les opérations qui plaisent à l'oncle
Sam. Si elles ne plaisent pas à l'oncle
Sam, et ben nous ne les condirons pas ou
nous les condirons dans des conditions
fortement dégradées. Donc ça ça plaide
immédiatement hein pour un un rebond,
pour une volonté très forte d'arriver à
construire cette autonomie. Le drame,
c'est que les Français ne pourront
jamais le faire seul et qu'on a à
convaincre tous ces pays qui préfèrent
rester dans l'illusion de cette de cette
de cette défense parce que politiquement
c'est plus intéressant de pas dépenser
trop d'argent dans la défense et de
distribuer dans les dans les aides
sociales des pays considérés. Donc là,
on a une vraie difficulté, ce que
j'espère vivement. On réagira mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on réagisse avant la
3è mondiale quoi. C'est ça le problème.
Évidemment quand on est au bout, tous
les pays donnent un coup au fond de la
piscine et finissent par remonter. Le
problème là, c'est d'arriver à remonter
soit avant 2045, je par 2045, soit avant
la prochaine grave crise, soit avant
d'avoir laissé les tensions monter
tellement entre la la Russie et l'Europe
que ça débouche sur une sur une
catastrophe. Elle est tout à fait
possible. Et donc, il faut réagir avant,
comprendre que nos intérêts stratégiques
sont de plus en plus différents, voire
divergents des intérêts américains. Donc
se doter de l'autonomie et de la
capacité à parler par nous-mêmes et à
agir par nous-mêmes.
Donc si si je vous comprends bien,
[raclement de gorge] nos intérêts ont
pris un autre chemin
que ceux ceux des États-Unis. Est-ce que
nos intérêts sont plus proches de ceux
de la Russie ?
Alors, je je je [rires]
je crois pas que la question se pose
comme ça. Je je crois que la la question
se pose enfin nos intérêts sont
convergents avec les intérêts russes si
on va un peu dans l'avenir. Quel est
l'intérêt commun de la Russie et des
pays européens ?
Résister à la Chine ?
Non, n'allons pas n'allons passer vite.
C'est de vivre en bonne entente en
Eurasie. Ça c'est quelque chose qui est
fondamental. Il y a la Chine, mais il y
a d'abord la Russie. Donc il faut
arriver à faire baisser les tensions et
à se considérer comme des partenair.
Comment on fait baisser les tensions ?
D'abord, on arrête d'être lié aux
États-Unis qui eux ont intérêt à ces
tensions-là. D'accord ? Il y a il y a
cette cet intérêt et puis il y a il y a
chez les Américains une certaine
maladresse hein.
Pourquoi est-ce que la Russie devient
cette cette Russie nation qui crée
monsieur Poutine au fond ? Qui crée
monsieur Poutine ? C'est George
Boubouche qu'il crée qu'il crée parce
que la main qui était tendue par
monsieur Clinton, la politique de la
main tendue la main a été retirée hein
au moment de l'arrivée des
néoconservateurs aux affaires à partir
de de 2001. Et donc l'Amérique va
poursuivre un certain nombre de
politiques qui ne peuvent être vécues
que comme agressives par les les Russes
et la Russie. D'où ce surgissement ? Ces
politiques en étant un peu schématique,
il y en a eu trois. La première
politique et on a vu tout à l'heure un
peu les raisons de cette affaire là,
c'est l'élargissement de l'OTAN. Quand
le l'OTAN commence à avoir des pour
parler avec l'Ukraine, que fait la
Russie ? elle va se faire en sorte que
ce ne soit pas possible. On sait que
l'OTAN ne peut pas intégrer des pays en
guerre ou en ou en rébellion. Donc on va
avoir créé l'affaire du Donbas, se se se
débrouiller pour que ça ne soit pas
possible. Donc quand on approche là, je
reviens un tout petit peu en arrière là,
il est dans la culture stratégique russe
de ne pas supporter à ses marches
immédiates un quelqu'un qu'elle peut
considérer comme un adversaire
potentiel. Il faut qu'entre elle et
l'adversaire potentiel benit un peu
d'espace de manière voilà ça a toujours
été comme ça dans l'histoire de la
Russie. Donc quand je pousse l'OTAN vers
la Russie et je le pousse de deux
manières vers l'Ukraine avec l'Ukraine
et la Geéorgie, elle réagit la Russie.
On se rappelle de la guerre en Geéorgie
en 2008 je crois sauf erreur de ma part
hein qui l'a déclenché. On sait pas trop
mais de toute façon elle serait arrivée.
Sacvil accuse monsieur Poutine qui
accuse et cetera mais de toute façon
elle elle aurait été là. D'accord. Donc
première manœuvre agressive de
l'Occident si on veut appeler ça comme
ça hein, c'est l'élargissement de l'OTAN
jusqu'à toucher la Russie. Ce qui on le
sait historiquement n'est pas
supportable. n'est pas supportable.
D'accord. Deuxième politique très
agressive le déploiement du bouclier
antimissile
dans en Pologne en Roumanie. les dans
dans les pays de l'Est, hein. Il est le
paradoxe le paradoxe peut-être pas
encore complètement intégré par par vos
auditeurs, le paradoxe de la dissuation
nucléaire, c'est que plus vous êtes
protégé, plus vous êtes dangereux. C'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu un un traité ABM,
un antibalistique missile de manière à
empêcher la protection et le l'équilibre
de la terreur résidait dans le fait que
étant susceptible d'être frappé par un
par mon adversaire, je n'avais aucun
intérêt à l'attaquer et c'est bien le
risque de la destruction qui m'empêchait
de vouloir détruire l'autre.
À partir du moment où l'Amérique est
protégée, en fait elle le sera jamais
parce que c'est c'est un truc
impossible, mais à partir du moment où
on cherche à se protéger, la Russie ne
peut que se sentir agressée parce que
l'Amérique, si elle est protégée,
pourraquer de manière en en restant
protégé de de d'éventuelles frappes
russes. Et donc on voit bien que cette
manœuvre de déploiement, même si on
explique que c'est pour l'Iran, elle ne
peut être vécue que comme agressive. Et
puis on a eu en même temps et encore une
fois c'est la politique de George
Abulouche, le la tentative de
contournement de la Russie par les
politiques d'Asie centrale,
l'Ozbekistan, le Kazakhstan et cetera.
Alors ça ça a pas fonctionné. Ça a pas
fonctionné pour une raison simple, c'est
que les colonies russes à l'intérieur de
ces pays qui ont souvent été éjectés par
Staline d'ailleurs ces russes-là, mais
la partie russe de ces pays est
tellement importante que ils sont restés
attachés eux à leur grand-mère patrie
qui était quand même la Russie. Mais
donc euh euh ces tensions là ont été
créées par par les par les États-Unis et
on voit bien que ça n'est pas dans notre
intérêt. Donc nous devons comment éviter
la montée des tensions ? Nous devons
arriver à avoir une politique autonome
vis-à-vis de la Russie. Pour l'instant,
elle ne l'est pas. Euh un un Shingtang
faisait le calcul où il y a eu des
grandes manœuvres russes il y a quelques
semaines ou quelques quelques mois.
Un Shingtang faisait le calcul du nombre
total de troupes de l'OTAN en exercice
au même moment. Nous, on a beaucoup
rallé à dire c'est c'est dangereux, vous
faites des des manœuvres et cetera, mais
le nombre de troubles de l'OTAN en train
de faire des manœuvres en même temps
était deux fois plus important. juste en
face
juste en face ou un peu partout mais
dans dans l'OTAN donc au même moment sur
le territoire européen de l'OTAN et donc
on on voit bien si vous voulez que cette
agressivité nous en sommes un un des
facteurs et quand je dis nous c'est pas
nous européens c'est nous européens via
l'OTAN et l'OTAN via les États-Unis et
donc c'est pour ça que l'autonomie
stratégique de l'Europe est quelque
chose qui est fondamental et vers vers
lequel on doit aller et c'est pour ça
que monsieur Macron sur ce point a
totalement raison Et je salue son
courage. Je salue son courage parce que
c'est pas du tout le discours, c'est pas
du tout le discours ambiant cette
affaire là hein. Et il le dit hein, il
l'a dit cet été. Il continue à lire et
il a parfaitement raison. C'est vital
pour l'Europe et c'est vital pour nous.
Et cette armée européenne
si si invoquée par monsieur Macron, ça
va pas être une armée allemande en fin
de compte ?
Alors et euh
la la il faut il faut faire attention au
terme. D'accord ? Et je crois que les
gens de bon sens ne peuvent pas accepter
le concept de nation européenne.
Il faut parler de défense de l'Europe,
il faut parler de je sais pas quoi ça
mais mais pas d'armée européenne.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Une armée est
composée de citoyens. Tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de citoyen européen, il n'y
aura pas d'armée européenne. D'accord ?
Il peut y avoir une armée française
parce qu'il y a une France qui existe et
donc des citoyens français qui peuvent
accepter de mourir pour la France. Quand
un soldat meurt, euh un soldat français
meurt, il meurt parce que il est il
adhère aux valeurs de la France, il
adhère à la France elle-même et cetera.
La question de savoir pour qui peut-on
faire mourir de ça ? Pour qui un soldat
peut-il accepter de mourir ? Il y a
c'est pas le seul élément mais il meurt
pour sa patrie. Et donc tant que
l'Europe n'est pas vécue comme une
patrie et on en est loin hein, on ne
pourra pas avoir d'armée européenne. On
peut avoir une nation des armées
européennes. On peut avoir une armée des
armées d'Europe. Ça ça existe. Donc on
peut avoir un système d'intégration hein
qui nous permettent d'abord de conduire
des opérations. Aujourd'hui l'Europe est
pas vraiment capable de le faire hein.
un système qui permette encore une fois
si les
ceux qui peuvent donner des ordres he
qui peut donner des ordres à l'armée
européenne, il faudrait qu'il une
autorité politique supranationale
capable de dire à un soldat allemand un
soldat français un soldat finlandais
vous allez mourir ensemble on sait bien
qu'on en est pas là on sait bien qu'on
en est pas là donc ça viendra peut-être
un jour mais on en est à des décennies
donc le point n'est pas là est d'assurer
la défense de l'Europe en faisant une
armée des nations européennes. Ça c'est
possible. N'allons pas trop loin. Donc
est-ce que ce sera l'armée allemande ?
La réponse est non. L'armée, elle sera
l'armée de toutes les nations européenne
qui vous qui auront compris que
l'autonomie de l'Europe est l'autonomie
stratégique, donc l'autonomie de défense
est importante, que la voie l'Europe est
importante et que donc il faut
construire cela. Quant à l'armée
allemande aujourd'hui, elle est dans un
état de toute façon qui ne lui permet
pas de faire des opérations, hein.
L'armée française n'est pas dans un état
remarquable, mais elle est quand même
sans coudée aujourd'hui au-dessus de
au-dessus de de l'armée allemande. Donc
armée européenne, non, ça n'a pas de
sens puisqu'une armée européenne
supposerait des citoyens européens qui
seraient dirigé par une autorité
poluropéenne politique légitime. On en
est à des décennies. Donc pour
l'instant, contendons-nous de vouloir
avoir une armée des nations européennes
ou une armée des armées européennes. Ça
c'est possible.
Vous avez vu la la présentation des
nouvelles armes de la Russie par
Vladimir Poutine.
Lesquels ?
Euh tout ce qui est euh missiles
hypersoniques
et et des drones hypersoniques.
Oui. Et alors,
est-ce qu'on est capable de se protéger
contre ça ?
Et bien alors
la question la question c'est pour
l'Europe parce qu'on parle on est
toujours sur l'Europe.
La la question pour l'Europe c'est que
aujourd'hui elle ne elle n'a pas elle ne
fait pas l'effort de recherche qui lui
permettrait de trouver rapidement d'une
part les parades et et d'autre part les
armes. Ça c'est bien aussi un des
problèmes que doit régler l'armée, la
défense européenne, arriver à avoir des
programmes de de recherche qui lui
permettent d'avancer de dans dans la
recherche d'armement performant. Donc je
vous pose, vous me posez la question
aujourd'hui la France est pas capable de
de les effendre contre un certain nombre
d'armes parce que mais personnes
peut-être parce que les contre les armes
hypersoniques, c'est comme le missile de
creuser, on sait pas faire quoi de toute
façon. C'est pour ça que la réponse
n'est pas dans euh dans l'amélioration
constante des arsenaux. La réponse, elle
est dans l'instauration d'un système
politique viable en Eurasie. Et elle est
là la elle est là la réponse. La course
aux armements, elle elle a jamais elle a
jamais conduit à la paix. Ça s'est
jamais passé comme ça, hein. Et alors,
vous pourriez me citer le cas de la de
la de la guerre froide qui a quand même
été une course aux armements et et la
Russie c'est et la Russie s'est
effondrée, hein. C'est la guerre des
étoiles de monsieur Rigan euh au début
des années 80. C'est c'est quand même
profondément c'est quand même
profondément ça. Mais je dirais que le
problème est pas de dire on peut pas se
protéger et cetera. Quand quand vous
cherchez et quand vous accumulez les
armements, à la fin ça pète quoi. C'est
c'est toujours comme ça. Donc le
problème est pas là. Oui, d'une part, il
faut arriver à rassembler nos budgets de
recherche et se donner des projets et
trouver notre autonomie par rapport aux
Américains, ne pas attendre que les
Américains trouvent les armes qui nous
vendront hors de prix parce qu'on les
aura pas et cetera. Donc, il y a un
effort à faire. Mais je ça il faut le
faire, c'est évident mais je pense que
le le le problème dépasse ça. Le
problème problème géopolitique hein, il
faut le problème et la baisse détention
arriver à faire en sorte que monsieur
Poutine ne soit pas notre ennemi. Vous
parliez de la Chine tout à l'heure. Moi,
je ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent que
la Chine est une menace militaire. À
court terme. Enfin, vous et moi, on aura
disparu de cette terre avant qu'elle
devienne une menace militaire. Mais en
tout cas hein, il est clair que quelque
part face à la Chine, les intérêts
russes et et européens sont assez
semblables là aussi. Donc on a intérêt
plutôt à travailler ensemble, à trouver
une façon de vivre ensemble et de
traiter des problèmes plutôt que euh
plutôt que d'essayer de les de les
traiter de de les traiter nous-mêmes.
Donc le problème il est géopolitique, le
problème il est politique. N'imaginons
pas que la technique, que la
technologie, que les armements règlent
les problèmes géostratégiques. Pas du
tout. C'est une toute petite composante.
L'armement, la technique, l'armement ne
joue que sur les bas niveaux de la
guerre. la technique et la tactique, les
niveaux supérieurs politiques,
stratégiques, il s'agit de de de
politique de relation dans lequel on
doit avoir une perception systémique du
monde dans lequel l'économie a beaucoup
plus de place que les armements, dans
lequel le politique, la diplomatie sont
beaucoup plus importants. Donc
n'imaginons pas régler nos problèmes de
guerre demain en améliorant simplement
nos arsenaux et en améliorant la façon
dont nos troupes manœuvre. Ça c'est une
toute petite partie du problème et c'est
pas la partie la plus importante. C'est
une dans une nouvelle vision du monde,
dans une nouvelle vision des intérêts
des vrais intérêts de l'Europe et de la
Russie qu'on arrivera à comprendre et
bien que nous devons repartir sur de
nouvelles bases pour arriver enfin un
jour à vivre ensemble sans compter sans
sans sans être sous la pression
diplomatique permanente de l'Amérique
dont les intérêts sont divergents des
nôtres.
On fait un petit tour par la Libye, la
Syrie. Est-ce que la Libye
on a on a créé une chi phénoménale
là-bas ? Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait en Libye
? Est-ce qu'on a apporté la démocratie
pour les petites filles ? Est-ce que on
a dzingué un grand dictateur ? Est-ce
que Qu'est-ce qu'on a Qu'est-ce qu'on a
été faire là-bas ? Est-ce qu'on a
désingué un gouvernement parce que ce
gouvernement-là avait financé une
campagne présidentielle ? Alors moi je
sais je je je sais pas mais après euh il
faut il faut il faut regarder l'arbre à
ces fruits. Il faut regarder l'arbre à
ces fruits. Il faut et comprendre ce que
n'avez pas compris monsieur Sarkozy, ce
que n'avait pas du tout compris monsieur
Bush non plus que [grognement] la guerre
n'est pas un objet. La guerre est un
sujet. C'est pas nouveau ça parce que
c'est Clauswiit qui l'écrit dans son de
la guerre dans dans les années années
années 30 si on veut si on veut 1830 si
si on veut être simple. La guerre a une
vie propre, c'est-à-dire que vous ne
pouvez pas créer la guerre et et
imaginer que vous allez la dominer. Ça
n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire du
monde. Jamais dans l'histoire du monde,
une guerre n'a produit ce qu'on en
attendait. C'est comme ça. Tactiquement,
une petite bataille. Oui, jamais la
guerre. Demander par exemple à
l'empereur Hooito quand il décide de
déclencher le bombardement sur Perbord
si en le 7 décembre 1941 est-ce qu'il
souhaite que son pays devienne le
premier terrain d'expérimentation de la
bombe atomique le 6 août 1945 ?
Évidemment pas. La guerre lui a
totalement échappé. Quand monsieur Bush
se lance dans cette stupide guerre en en
en Irak en 2003, son objectif n'est pas
de d'exploser le Moyen-Orient. Elle est
pas de créer Daesh. Elle est pas de
créer l'attentat de Bataclan, celui de
Nuis, celui de Stockholm ou celui de
Londres. Et pourtant, c'est le résultat.
La guerre lui a échappé. On ne termine
jamais la guerre sur ce qu'on avait
voulu. Nous sommes rentrés en guerre
pour que la Pologne vive en dehors des
des totalitarismes en 19 euh 39. quand
on est rentré en guerre 1939, ben la
guerre on l'a faite après un an de phony
war mais on l' déclaré en 39 pour que la
Pologne vive dans ses frontière à l'abri
des totalitarismes. Quand on estime
avoir gagné la guerre en 45 et nous
faisons partie des vainqueurs, la
Pologne a complètement changé de
frontière et elle est complètement sous
le totalitarisme
russe et
soviétique
russe. Donc donc on voit bien que c'est
un troisème exemple, la guerre produit
jamais. Et donc les acteurs qui
connaissent pas bien et George Bouche
connaissait pas bien et monsieur Sarguzi
connaissait pas bien.
Il était pas bien conseillé.
Il s'était il ne connaissait pas bien.
Alors il pas bien conseillé. C'est c'est
une je peux vous on peut aller dans dans
cette affaire là, mais il se lance dans
cette affaire là en croyant que la
guerre est redevenu un outil rentable de
réalisation des visées politiques. Et
donc monsieur monsieur le président
Sarkozy se lance dans cette affaire-là
probablement d'abord pour des motifs des
motifs de politique intérieure. ce en
quoi il est comme les autres. Dans 80 %
des cas, les guerres commencent pour des
raisons de politique intérieure.
L'exemple le plus frappant bien sûr,
c'est la la tentative de reconquête des
Malouines par je j'oublie le nom du du
général qui était aux affaires en qui
était président argentin à ce moment-là.
Mais quand l'Argentine se lance dans
cette affaire là, c'est parce que le
pouvoir perpied, il faut partir dans une
aventure. C'est une vieille histoire.
Donc monsieur Sarkozy a un problème
d'élection, il élection bientôt et
cetera. Donc il très probablement ça
c'est ça joue un rôle majeur. Après il y
a ce qu'on annonce. Vous savez bien
qu'aujourd'hui les guerres ne peuvent
être que des guerres à prétention morale
parce que les peuples n'acceptent que
les guerres à prétention morale comme le
dit Monique Cantosperber qui dirige
l'école normale supérieure aujourd'hui
des guerres à prétention morale. Donc il
faut trouver un truc et donc on on va
dire mais monsieur Kaddafi va écraser
tout va tuer dans le sang tous les tous
les habitants de de Benazi. Quelqu'un le
dit, il a une chemise blanche, on le
sait, il se promène et cetera. Déjà,
vous savez bien, monsieur Bernard Henry
Lévi va dire ça. C'est une thèse, il y a
beaucoup d'autres thèses sérieuses qui
disent "C'était totalement impossible
cette histoire. Ça ça se serait pas
passé." Mais admettons que ce soir que
que que ce fut vrai, je pense que il eut
était légitime de lancer la guerre,
d'arrêter les chars de monsieur Kaddafi
et ensuite de se lancer dans autre
chose, c'est-à-dire de pas chercher à
gagner la guerre. On peut pas gagner
l'air, ça ça n'existe pas. Donc rétablir
une créer des nouvelles conditions qui
auraient permis au aux deux par aux deux
parties de de parler et cetera. Mais on
est allé beaucoup trop loin. On est allé
effectivement jusqu'à la destruction
d'un pilier très important de la
stabilité du Sahel. Et c'est ça le grand
problème. C'est-à-dire que on a fait la
guerre pour la guerre et on n'a pas fait
ce qui est fondamental. C'est quand on
fait la guerre, on doit la [grognement]
faire en espérant et en souhaitant et en
prenant les moyens de de de déboucher
sur un état de paix meilleur que le
précédent. Donc, on ne s'est pas
vraiment préoccupé de la paix. On se dit
ça va s'arranger tout seul, ils vont se
mettre mais non, c'est jamais comme ça.
Et donc, on sait bien ce qui s'est
passé, hein. Cette guerre de Libye a a
eu comme conséquence, non voulu
initialement par le chaos au Sahel.
chaos qui est organisé au Sahel
désormais pour 30 ans ou 25 ans. Et nos
soldats français qui sont là-bas
maintenant depuis 2013, ils seront
probablement encore en 2043. Ils y
seront probablement encore parce que on
n' pas les moyens de régler ça. Ça
entraîné la déstabilisation du Sahel et
également la déstabilisation des pays de
l'Afrique noire sub-saharienne. Et donc
on voit on voit que on voit que les les
conséquences géopolitiques de cette
décision
très probablement prise à à la légère et
enfin sans sans bien se rendre compte de
ce qu'est la guerre et bien a des a des
conséquences terribles à des
conséquences terribles aujourd'hui et
une grande partie des flux migratoires
qui ont entraîné tout ce qu'on sait
comme bouleversement en Europe dont on
se plaint avec les nationalismes et
cetera et bien sont là, ils sont c'est
les deux erreurs stratégiques majeures
de du 20e siècle sont bien la guerre en
Irak en 2003 et la guerre en Libye en
2011. Et c'est bien la conjonction de
ces deux erreurs nées de la
méconnaissance de ce qui est la guerre
qui va entraîner la déstabilisation du
monde, la création d'Ah, les attentats,
les le peut-être explosion de l'Europe,
sa séparation en deux entre les
démocrates et les nationalistes. Bien
que j'aime pas du tout cette cette
dicotomie impropre. On on voit bien que
ces conséquences ont été terribles. Il
ne faut pas jouer avec la guerre. Vous
ne pouvez pas maîtriser la guerre. Et
c'est pour ça que dans les guerres, je
pense que il y a il y a il y a des
guerres dans lesquelles que vous êtes
obligé de conduire. La France était
obligée d'aller en 2013 euh régler le
problème des euh des djihadistes de de
Laadra, des Hipor au Mali parce que si
nous ne l'avions pas fait, alors le
Bataclan n'aurait pas eu lieu en 2015
mais en 2014 parce que ces gens-là dans
la forteresse qu'ils avaient installé
dans l'Adrar des Efor n'avaient qu'une
envie et qu'une volonté. c'était d'aller
apporter le feu, le sang et et l'enfer
en Europe. Et donc il fallait y aller.
Donc ça n'était pas ça une guerre de
choix, c'était une guerre d'obligation
et les nations doivent conserver la
capacité de se protéger, donc d'arrêter
des sources de violence. Donc il faut
conserver cette capacité-là. Les guerres
de choix sont toujours des erreurs. Les
guerres de choix poser la question à
monsieur Hitler, hein. Euh et lui, il
est obligé de se suicider dans son
binqueur. Donc ça c'est quand même assez
mal terminé pour lui. Et puis pas que
pour lui. Et puis pas que pour lui. Et
mais les guerres de choix, les deux
dernières grandes guerres de choix,
c'est la guerre de 2000 de 2003 en Irak
et la guerre de 2011 en Libye. Les
conséquences en sont terribles. Il ne
faut pas jouer avec la guerre. Et là se
pose un autre problème, c'est le
problème de la méconnaissance que nos
élites aujourd'hui [raclement de gorge]
ont de la guerre et de ce que sont les
armées et de ce qu'est le soldat.
Peut-on leur reprocher ? Non, on peut
pas leur reprocher. Les jeunes
générations qui sont qui est la vôtre,
qui viennent aux affaires, monsieur
Macron, il a pas fait son service
militaire. La guerre, il l'a jamais vu.
Il a vécu dans un monde en paix. Il il
ne connaît pas. Et on voit bien que la
la génération qui vient aux affaires,
elle elle ne connaîtra pas. Elle ne
connaîtra pas. Mais il faut prendre
conscience de cette affaire là. La
conscience de l'ignorance fait partie du
savoir et donc il faut savoir qu'ils ne
savent pas. Et donc il faut qu'à l'énat
dans lequel les armées, la guerre, la
défense est survolée pendant une journée
de travail sur 2 ans, il faut qu'on y
réfléchisse, que ces gens là aillent
dans les armées, que nos futurs
responsables qui viennent de nos futures
grandes écoles dont seront pendant des
des décennies encore issus nos élites,
que ces gens-là soient confrontés aux
armées, qu'il voi ce que c'est, qu'ils
comprennent, qu'on les projette de
manière à ce qu'il ne fassent plus ces
erreurs. Les deux grandes erreurs
stratégiques, les deux dernières grandes
erreurs stratégiques 2003 Irak, 2011
Libye sont déclenché par des hommes qui
ne connaissent rien à la guerre et rien
aux armées.
La Syrie.
Oui.
Bah Charelassad qui est toujours à la
tête de son état, qui a au moins 50 % de
sa population avec lui.
Oui.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait là-bas ? On y
va, on y va pas, on continue de tester
des armes, on continue de laisser ça à
la Russie.
Non mais on y va, on y va pour quoi
faire. Le problème c'est pas c'est pas
monsieur Hassan. Le problème c'est Da.
Le le problème
c'est pas le problème de de la Syrie,
c'est pas aussi des oléoduc, des
gazoduc.
Non mais le problème fondamental dans
cette affaire là, c'est c'est c'est Da.
On a et et heureusement, on est en train
de enfin on quand je dis on, c'est la la
coalition. Bon,
les Russes quoi.
Non non non non. Les Russes, vous pouvez
pas, vous avez pas le droit de dire ça.
Vous avez pas le droit de dire ça,
de minimiser l'impact qu'on a là-bas.
Non, non, vous avez pas le droit de dire
ça. Les soldats les soldats français se
sont battus, les soldats américains sont
battu. On a eu des morts en en en Irak.
Le on on le monsieur Poutine s'est
chargé essentiellement de la Syrie, mais
nous nous sommes occupés de l'Irak.
Enfin, nous nous les Français un peu et
les Américains beaucoup plus et cetera.
Donc, on peut pas dire c'est monsieur
Poutine, mais non. Il y a ce ce qui est
vrai, c'est qu'il y a eu le manque de
coordination. Le problème pourquoi ça
durait ça durait si longtemps que contre
Daesh, c'est parce que il y a pas eu une
unité de vue. Il y avait pas de
stratégie globale parce qu'il y avait
pas d'ambition commune et il y avait les
intérêts opposés. Bon, c'est ça qui fait
que ça a duré longtemps
les intérêts opposés c'est lesquels
lesquels ? Ben, je suis pas sûr que les
intérêts de monsieur Erdogan soient
exactement les mêmes que ce de monsieur
Poutine. Alors, ils ont fait alliance
parce qu'ils ont compris que les
intérêts de l'Arabie Saoudite soi
exactement les intérêts de l'Iran, que
les intérêts d'Israël soient exactement
euh les intérêts de l'Arabie Saoudite.
On voit bien que toutes les parties
prenantes étaient dans cette affaire-là
mais avaient des intérêts divergents et
vous ne pouvez pas faire de stratégies
efficaces si vous n'avez pas d'intérêt
convergent. Ça a été le cas la deuxième
guerre mondiale et et et l'exemple
incroyable hein. Cette guerre est gagnée
par des gens qui se haïse mais qui
acceptent pendant un certain temps de
coordonner concrètement leurs efforts
vers un seul but qui est la chute du 3e
rich. Donc entre le 21 juin 1941, début
de l'opération Barbarossa
quand les Allemands rentrent, franchise
et partent en et partent en Russie. Et
puis le 8 mai 1945, les deux meilleurs
ennemis du monde, monsieur Staline et
monsieur Roselt, se mettent d'accord sur
un objectif parce qu'ils ont une vision
simple et commune. Et pendant toute la
durée de la guerre, on va avoir de
grandes conférences stratégiques qui
sont la deuxième guerre mondiale. C'est
Teran, c'est Casablanca, c'est Québec,
c'est Washington. Voilà, toutes ces
grandes réunions qui vont permettre en
permanence d'aller vers le résultat
final. On est dans le cas de Daesh, on
est dans un cas complètement différent.
Jamais les grands acteurs ne se sont mis
d'accord à part la destruction de Daesh,
ne se sont mis d'accord sur sur
l'objectif. Or dans une guerre, il faut
pas se mettre une guerre qui est à but
négatif est une guerre qui va être
perdue parce que la paix ultérieur sera
perdue. Vous devez avoir un but positif,
c'est-à-dire bien une vision de la paix
commune. Donc pour que cette affaire-là
soit bâtie sur une stratégie, il lui
fallu que les grands acteurs aient une
vision commune de ce que doit être le
moyen et le proche-orient. Ça a pas été
le cas. Donc on a eu grand mal. Donc
chacun a fait son petit boulot dans son
coin parce que il y avait quand même un
certain nombre de de perceptions
communes d'Aesh embêté tout le monde.
Ouvre une parenthèse, une question
d'internet. Quand on parle des intérêts
d'un pays, on parle d'intérêt des
peuples, d'intérêts économique,
d'intérêt des élites. [soupir]
Le le le le la réponse c'est que l'État
devrait arriver à faire la synthèse et
vous n'êtes une nation que si tous ces
intérêts là sont convergents. Le
problème d'un pays comme la France,
c'est qu'elle est pas suffisamment, je
dis pas de moins en moins parce que
j'espère qu'on la reconstruira une
nation parce que on a des intérêts
divergents et que chacun se sent pas
membre d'une d'une même communauté. Donc
si on est capable de se poser cette
question là, c'est que et ben il y a
quelque chose à faire. Si on est capable
d'avoir aujourd'hui des gilets jaunes,
des machins, c'est que on a une espèce
de dislocation de la nation qui est
parfaitement malsine. Il ne faut pas
qu'on il faut que l'État puisse
représenter un l'intérêt global. Et si
c'est pas comme ça, il y a un véritable
problème et qu'il faut que les intérêts
soient les intérêts de la nation qui est
représenté par un état. C'est un modèle,
c'est jamais parfait mais on doit y
tendre. Et c'est et c'est bien quand le
président Roosevelt représente oui les
intérêts de toute l'Amérique, qu'elle
est forte et que l'Amérique devient une
machine de guerre et une machine à
produire une armée et qui va l'emporter.
C'est dans ces conditions-là qu'une
nation peut peut l'emporter. Donc je
reviens sur notre affaire Irak Syrie. On
ne peut pas dire que il y a que monsieur
Poutine. C'est ça. C'est c'est
absolument fa
pour la Syrie. Pour la Syrie.
Oui. Pour la Syrie. Oui. Mais la Syrie
c'est un problème global si vous voulez.
On a les affaires de Daesh au
Moyen-Orient. Bon et cette affaire-là,
Daesh, c'est le premier problème.
Maintenant, les affaires de monsieur
Assad en Syrie, ce sont des affaires
intérieur. On est on est désolé. Vous ne
pouvez pas à la fois dire "On pit trop
d'impôt".
Donc ne pas accepter qu'on ait une armée
capable de dire la loi dans le monde,
hein. Et puis dire, il faut faire
quelque chose contre monsieur Hassad.
l'armée française est totalement
incapable de déployer aujourd'hui
euh euh ne serait-ce qu'une brigade pour
aller faire la guerre en Syrie. On est
incapable de le faire parce que ben on n
pas on n pas payé suffisamment d'impôts.
Et donc ça ça c'est quelque chose qui
est important. Nous ne sommes plus au
centre du monde et nous ne pouvons plus
dire et faire respecter la loi. Alors on
peut avoir des états d'amoraux. Très
bien. Moi, j'en ai je trouve pas ça très
bien le je abominable. atroce le gazage
des populations de la Gouta par monsieur
Assad. Mais je n'y peux rien. Je n'y
peux rien. C'est comme ça. On aurait pu
quelque chose en 2013. Rappelez-vous
aujourd'hui, on n'y peut rien. Donc
essayons de de défendre ce qui reste à
défendre l'Europe, la France et cetera,
mais il y a des choses qui nous
dépassent. Ou alors il faut que le
peuple français en masse, au lieu de
prendre des gilets jaunes, prenne des
gilets par bal et demandent à aller se
battre là-bas. Mais ils ne le feront
pas. Donc on peut avoir des états d'âme,
on peut avoir des principes moraux et
j'en ai, mais aussi être réaliste. Il y
a des choses contre lesquelles on ne
peut rien. Qu'est-ce qui nous Qu'est-ce
qui compte pour les Français aujourd'hui
? Ce qui compte pour les Français
aujourd'hui,
c'est un frigo rempli.
Oui. Oui, vous avez ou c'est un frigo
rempli. Oui, vous avez. Évidemment, on
peut on peut on peut dire chose comme
ça, mais vis-à-vis de leur sécurité,
vis-à-vis de la Syrie, bah il faut que
la Syrie soit stabilisée et que ben le
le judialisme et les terroristes en
soient éradiqué. Alors ben oui, c'est
pas bien et c'est pas exactement comme
nous on aurait aimé le faire peut-être
mais nous on n'est pas capable de le
faire. Donc il faut admettre que
d'autres que d'autres le fasse. Et quoi
qu'il arrive, on a intérêt. On voit bien
aujourd'hui que l'idée stupide de faire
tomber des dictateurs, c'est une très
très belle idée morale. Formidable.
Formidable. Seulement ça fout le bordel.
Seulement hein. On a fait tomber
monsieur Kaddafi hein. Tout le tout le
tout le Sahel et toute l'Afrique noire
subsaahélienne et et est en cha. On a
fait tomber monsieur Saddam Hussein et
bien le Moyen-Orient a le Moyen-Orient a
explosé. Donc faut-il mieux supporter un
tyran qui est parfaitement amoral mais
finalement qui déclenche beaucoup moins
de violence que la guerre qui est est
consécutive à la tentative de sa de son
de son de son éviction. Donc je crois
que je crois qu'il faut être réaliste.
J'ouvre une autre parenthèse question
d'internet. Ce sont les impôts qui
financent l'armée. Point d'interrogation
ou c'est la dette ? Lien entre banque,
guerre.
Écoutez, ce qui finance ce qui finance
l'armée, c'est l'argent public. Bon,
c'est l'argent public, mais on sait
aujourd'hui que l'argent l'argent public
est et repose très largement sur la
dette. pas complètement moitié moitié
pour la France mais mais mais presque.
Donc pour répondre à la question, c'est
moitié à moitié moitié moitié PIB
français production et et moitié. C'est
bien le problème d'ailleurs, on sait on
le sait bien on sait bien que le
problème de l'endettement de tous les
pays d'ailleurs parce que c'est quand
même la Chine qui finance, on le sait
bien l'armée l'armée l'armée américaine
hein. Voilà. Bon et on sait bien que le
la c'est un autre problème, c'est pas
exactement un problème qui nous
préoccupe, mais le la le déficit public
est un est un problème majeur en France
est un problème majeur en France. Et
tant que ce problème-là n'aura pas été
adressé et ben euh il grèvera lourdement
notre nos capacités d'autonomie
d'autonomie d'autonomie stratégique.
C'est évident parce que il faut il faut
emprunter. Euh j'emprunte, c'est les
générations futures qui payent et
cetera. Donc on a on a un cycle on a un
cycle vicieux. Alors sur sur sur cette
affaire, je crois que on sort d'un monde
où l'Occident était porteur des valeurs
qui étaient qui étaient les valeurs
universelles. Mais pourquoi
étaient-elles universelles ? Elles
étaient universelles parce que notre
épée était longue et qu'elle était
aiguisée.
Toutes les valeurs ont d'abord été
portées, poussé par l'épée. Le
missionnaire n'est venu qu'après.
Et donc, on assiste au phénomène inverse
aujourd'hui. Notre épée s'émousse petit
à petit et donc nos valeurs, elles
reviennent à l'endroit où on peut les
défendre. Et donc je crois qu'il faut
admettre parce que de toute façon on n'a
pas les moyens de faire autrement et pas
un français veut veut doubler le budget
des armées française même s'ils
acceptent à juste titre qu'il soit un
peu augmenté et bien il faut admettre
que nous ne pourrons défendre nos
valeurs qu'en fonction de la portée de
nos canons. C'est comme ça. Et donc il
faut admettre que dans d'autres parties
du monde on vivra avec d'autres valeurs.
Nos valeurs occidentales qui ont été
universelles et du ou du moins, nous
l'avons cru. le sont de moins en moins
la la partie du monde qui respecte nos
valeurs. Là, aller voir ce qu'est la
démocratie en Inde. Aller voir ce qu'est
la démocratie dans la plupart des pays
sont des démocratures comme dit monsieur
euh Bavrez à à juste titre. Nos valeurs
à nous, elles appartiennent à un monde
tout à fait réduit. Nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer à nouveau de les répondre comme
nous avons tenté de le faire et réussi
d'ailleurs au 19e et au 20e siècle.
Maintenant, je crois qu'il faut admettre
que d'autres hommes, d'autres
populations, d'autres États vivront avec
d'autres valeurs et que nous devrons le
supporter. Mais que si nous voulons que
ces valeurs-là restent chez ces gens-là,
nous devons nous-mêmes être capables de
défendre nos valeurs dans notre
précarré, dans notre Europe, dans notre
France. Et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
veiller à la défense de l'Europe et on
en revient à la défense européenne.
Vous parliez d'état d'â euh euh la Libye
euh les les marchés aux esclaves libiens
qui nous envoient des des flux de
migrants. Euh un bateau euh qui
s'appelait l'Aquarius euh qui allait les
repêcher pas très loin des côtes
libiennes pour éviter qu'il retombe dans
les marchés aux esclaves. Est-ce que
l'armée française est-ce que le
gouvernement français doit avoir des
états d'âes ? Est-ce queon doit utiliser
les bateaux français pour aller repêcher
les gens ? Est-ce que on doit utiliser
nos avions pour aller fracasser le
marché aux esclaves ? Est-ce qu'on doit
faire un effet tampon, c'est-à-dire
créer un un territoire neutre juste en
face des côtes pour faire les prémisses
d'une garde prétorienne européenne ?
Est-ce que les flux migratoires doivent
être encadrés ? Qu'est-ce que vous avez
une idée un peu là-dessus ? Bien sûr,
bien sûr. Alors, alors moi je l'ai euh
j'ai pas
euh euh reciter la citation euh bien
connue, hein. On peut pas accepter toute
la misère du monde. C'est c'est c'est
juste vrai. Bon, c'est c'est c'est juste
vrai. C'estd que à un moment donné, les
nations, elles doivent elles doivent
survivre. elles doivent survivre et soit
on accepte définitivement de de de
perdre nos façons de vivre, nos valeurs
et cetera et alors les portes sont
grande ouverte et et la démocratie du
monde fait que notre propre civilisation
va disparaître. C'est une affaire
d'année. C'est une affaire c'est une
affaire c'est une affaire d'année. Soit
on a quand même envie de vivre un peu
comme on a envie de vivre et cetera et
donc on peut pas admettre les flux
migratoires sans aucune sans aucune
restriction. Ce qui veut dire que la
morale chrétienne
ou la morale tout court dit "OK, je peux
pas faire ça" et donc il est de mon
devoir de faire en sorte que ces flux
diminuent mais naturellement. Le
problème il y a toutes les forteresses
sont tournées. Toutes les forteresses
s'écrouent un jour donc on ne peut pas
imaginer arrêter ses flux uniquement par
une frontière. Ça ce n'est pas possible.
Et donc on a bien le problème je le
problème doit être traité en amont et
chaque pays a ses responsabilités dans
cette affaire là. Et l'Afrique pas
l'Afrique mais la la l'Europe mais la
France a des responsabilités. l'Europe
et la France he tout ça, on a des
responsabilités directes en Afrique.
Nous direct en Afrique, on doit bien
comprendre mais c'est c'est juste de la
physique, c'est juste de la démographie
de de la mathématique que le milliard
d'africains qui va naître dans les 30
ans ou 35 ans à venir
le milliard 4,
ça dépend de enfin admir qu'elle va
doubler la population, elle va passer de
1 à 2 de 3 de 4. Bon dans les dans le
quart de siècle et le demi-siècle
prochain, ça sera comme ça. ces gens-là,
si ce pays, si l'Afrique ne n'a pas ne
propose pas suffisamment de de
ressources et suffisamment de stabilité,
mais ces gens-là ne resteront pas en
Afrique. C'est c'est mathématique, c'est
comme ça. Donc, ils iront ailleurs, là
où ils pourront vivre. Et où est-ce que
ça ça se passe ? Ça se passe évidemment
au nord de chez eux. Ça se passe au nord
de chez eux. Donc la politique,
ça se passe à Mayotte aussi ou ça se
passe à Mayotte.
Oui, mais OK. Donc il peut on peut avoir
une politique de court terme qui dit
est-ce qu'il faut les bateaux, les
machins ? Mais c'est pas le fond du
problème. Le fond du problème c'est
d'arriver à s'engager suffisamment en
Afrique pour arriver à régler les
problèmes au fond. Mais ça demande un ça
demande de faire de la ça demande de
faire de la stratégie. C'est-à-dire
qu'il faut arriver à faire comprendre à
la population française que leur intérêt
est qu'on dépense leur argent pour aller
euh s'occuper de l'économie des pays de
la zone saélienne et cetera. Donc c'est
très compliqué. On n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui, peut-être qu'il y a un
problème de communication, mais on
n'arrive pas à leur faire comprendre
aujourd'hui que le l'écologie est un
problème fondamental parce que c'est un
problème juste d'après-demain et que
donc euh on s'intéresse juste au
problème du jour. Alors, on n'arrive pas
à le faire en France. Alors, c'est ça la
grande complication et ça ça ne peut
être fait qu'au niveau de l'Europe. Et
là encore, l'Europe peut arriver à à
traiter traiter entre guillemets le
problème africain, c'est-à-dire à
participer de manière volontaire au
développement de l'Afrique, à la
stabilisation de l'Afrique. C'est c'est
un problème grave, mais ça demande une
vraie stratégie, ça demande une vraie
sacrifice, de vrais sacrifices et ça
demande une vraie compréhension des
enjeux futurs. Mais c'est absolument
c'est absolument fondamental.
On parle un peu de la France-Afrique.
C'est fini cette époque là ou on
continue d'avoir des comportements
prédateurs en Afrique sur les
ressources, sur les gouvernements, sur
les choses comme ça ?
Bon écoutez, alors vous savez que la la
Francrique, d'abord on a donné à ce à
cette à ce à ce à ce terme une
connotation péjorative qui qu'il avait
pas du tout qu'il avait pas du tout au
début. Bon, ce ce ce que alors euh
est-ce que la francphique s terminée ?
Moi je je j'en fais rien mais je c'est
c'est pas mon c'est pas mon problème he
mon problème c'est celui que je viens de
définir. Mon mon problème c'est de bien
se rendre compte que l'avenir de
l'Afrique et l'avenir de la France
quelque part ils sont quand même
extrêmement extrêmement mêlés. Alors
après qu' ait des on ne peut plus on ne
peut plus se se comporter en Afrique
comme on s'est comme on s'est parfois
comporté. Mais il faut bien comprendre
aussi que euh l'évolution des pays euh
africains euh elle elle est euh la la
France est pas responsable de tout,
hein. La France est pas responsable de
tout. La la on a sûrement raté la
prédécolonisation. Mais pouvait-on la
réussir ? La la question la question se
pose mais il est clair que là là là
encore quelque part un peu par égoïsme
on s'est dit c'est fini et un certain
nombre de dirigeants politiques n'ont
pas compris que les vrais problèmes
étaient des problèmes d'avenir. On a
traité ça un peu dans le court terme.
Quel est le problème des démocraties ?
le problème des démocraties et qu'elles
ne savent régler et prendre en compte
que les problèmes du court terme. Ça
c'est un vrai problème et qu'on voit
dans les rues aujourd'hui.
On parle un peu du Yémen.
Oui. Que voulez-vous qu'on en dise ?
Euh les chars français ils fonctionnent
bien au Yen.
Bah c'est pas les chars français, c'est
les chars qui ont été achetés.
Donc les chars made in France.
Mais et alors ? Et alors ? Et alors là,
vous savez, il faut il faut ce pourquoi
vendon de l'armement ? Pourquoi est-ce
que la France est-ce qu'il est amoral de
vendre de l'armement ? C'est pas une
question de moral. C'est pas une
question de moral. Vous devez poser des
principes fondamentaux. Quel est le
principe géopolitique fondamental de la
France ? C'est que la France, elle
recherche son autonomie. Avoir une
autonomie de défense, c'est avoir une
industrie autonome. Si et avoir une
industrie de défense autonome, quand on
a un petit marché national qui s'appelle
l'armée française, vous n'avez pas
d'autre choix que de vendre votre
armement à l'extérieur. Donc la question
est-ce qu'il est moral de vendre de
l'armement ou est-ce qu'il est moral de
revendiquer l'autonomie de la France ?
Parce que c'est ça. Si je pense qu'il
est normal que la France soit autonome
et bien il va falloir qu'elle vende de
l'armement. Et c'est pour ça que
l'Europe encore une fois est une
réponse. L'Europe encore une fois est
une réponse. Pourquoi est-ce que
l'industrie américaine de l'armement vit
? Elle vit elle vit parce que elle a un
marché suffisamment important qui
s'appelle les armées américaines. Donc
vous avez des industries, on a et la
France, elle ne peut pas faire vivre son
industrie d'armement dont elle a besoin
pour avoir son autonomie sur le marché
français. Donc elle est obligée de
vendre. Le cas du rafale est est
parfaitement emblématique.
Si nous n'avions pas gagné finalement
des marchés à l'export, et bien il
aurait finalement fallu arrêter les
chaînes. On était plus capable d'équiper
même nos armées françaises. On sait bien
que en dessous de 11 avions rafales
produits par an, d'Ass ne sait plus
faire parce que c'est juste ça ça il y a
plus aucun rendement économique.
D'accord ? Donc c'est plus possible.
Donc on voit bien qu'on vend l'arme.
Alors il se trouve qu'entend que il y a
combien de temps maintenant ? 20 ans je
pense à peu près, quelque chose comme
ça. On a vendu des charlescler à à Abu
Dhabi. Et ben très bien. C'est parce
qu'on a vendu des chars lecler à Abu
Dhabi qu'on a été capable d'en avoir.
Ensuite il faut admettre que ces chars
bon ils vont ils vont ils vont ils vont
vivre leur vie. La question peut se
poser de manière différente maintenant,
mais on ne peut pas reprocher à aux
dirigeants politiques il y a je 25 ans
probablement d'un quart de siècle
d'avoir rendu des Charles Lecler à Abu
Dhabi. Alors mais pourquoi ne fait-on
pas la guerre nous français à Abu Dhabi
? Pas Abu Dhabi pardon au Yémen, il faut
y aller. C'est quand même dégueulasse ce
qui se passe là-bas. Pourquoi va-t-on au
Mali et pourquoi ne va-ton pas au Yémen
? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on laisse faire
l'Arabie Saoudite le faire ?
Non, c'est pas ça la question. C'est
vous dites "C'est dégueulasse quand
même. On s'occupe du Mali, on s'occupe
pas du Yémen." Et ben oui, il y a de
poids de mesure. Il y aura toujours de
poids de mesure parce que nous ne sommes
pas capables parce que nous avons une
armée qui est capable de régler des
petits problèmes à proximité et que nous
n'avons pas une armée capable de
résoudre de régler des grands problèmes
loin.
Est-ce que Est-ce qu'au Yémémen il y a
des grands champs gaziers ?
Je sais pas. Moi, je connais pas ces
affaires là. Je connais pas. Je connais
pas. Mais ce que je veux dire, ce que ce
que ce que je veux dire, c'est queon de
poids, de mesure, il faut aller il faut
l'admettre. Est-ce que parce que nous ne
sommes pas capable matériellement,
financièrement d'agir au Yémen, nous ne
devons pas agir au Sahël ? Non, c'estàd
que la moralité du monde exige le de
poids de mesure. Et ça c'est c'est ça
fait partie du réalisme. Est-ce que nous
sommes allés faire la guerre en Tchenie
? Non.
Est-ce que c'était
à moral de pas y aller ? Non, nous n'en
avions pas les moyens et en même temps,
on la faisait ailleurs. Nous ne pouvons
pas tout faire. Et je crois que les bons
moralistes
qu'on trouve partout, les bonnes âmes,
il faut aller là, c'est des et cetera.
D'accord ? accepter de payer des impôts,
accepter de tripler le volume de l'armée
française, sinon soyez juste des
réalistes. Acceptez le de poids de
mesure et acceptez aussi que quand un
pays agit pour des raisons humanitaires,
il ne le fait jamais que quand il a
aussi des raisons économiques. Et c'est
bien comme ça. Sinon, il il n'agirait
jamais. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'un état agit
dans l'intérêt de sa nation, dans
l'intérêt de de son peuple.
On l'a vu en Libye. Ouais. On on agit on
agit dans l'intérêt et un un
gouvernement n'a pas le droit d'agir
d'utiliser ses armées si ça n'est pas il
il y a pas de légitimité à faire si
c'est pas dans l'
légitimité pour la Libye c'était quoi
déjà
la légitime pour la Libye ? Je c'était
je d'abord fallait-il le faire ? Moi je
crois pas je crois que c'est une guerre
stupide. Il fallait pas la faire. Donc
la légitimité elle était moyenne. La
preuve c'est que maintenant on est on
est en guerre au Sahel. Donc la
légitimité justement probablement elle y
était pas. Il fallait pas le faire. Et
donc ce que je veux dire ce que ce que
non mais ce que je veux dire de dans
cette affaire-là, c'est qu'il est normal
qu'à un moment donné le on est un
croisement des intérêts économiques et
des intérêts humanitaires. Parce que
s'il y a pas d'intérêt économique, il y
aura pas d'intervention humanitaire. Et
ça aussi le réaliste, il doit le savoir.
Et que plus il y aura l'intérêt
économique d' plus un pays aura un
intérêt économique à intervenir et mieux
il interviendra. Si nous avions un
intérêt nous français économique très
fort au Yémen, on irait mais on en a
pas. Alors on y va pas. Il y a pas total
qui parce que rappelez-vous le conflit
au Yémen, il a pas commencé 2 semaines
après que des insurgés et commencé à
mettre leurs mains sur un champ gazier.
Non mais écoutez un je ne sais pas et je
n'en parle pas parce que je sais pas
parce que c'est pas mon sujet parce que
c'est pas mon sujet. Moi, je veux
simplement vous dire ce que je vous dis,
hein, c'est que euh c'est que il est euh
vous ne pouvez pas euh reprocher à un
état. Quand l'Arabie Saoudite
intervient, elle a probablement des
intérêts économiques. Mais mais c'est
normal, elle interviendrait pas si elle
a pas d'intérêt économique. Il y a il y
a c'est on peut pas être un idéaliste,
un moraliste en disant il faut y aller
pour des raisons pures. Vous n'avez pas
le droit d'y aller pour des raisons
pures parce que vous trahissez votre
votre propre pays si vous le faites. Si
vous voulez,
vendre un laboratoire P4 à l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'est normal.
Je je sais pas. Écoutez la l'Arabie
Saoudite l'Arabie Saoudite on
rappelez-moi un laboratoire P4 c'est
quoi ?
Et c'est vous qui allez me dire
c'est bactériologique chimique.
Écoutez je je sais je sais je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut le problème c'est
pas tel ou tel type d'armement et
cetera.
Quand les puissances européennes telles
que l'Allemagne suspend ses ventes
d'armes
à ce type de pays. Est-ce que nous on
doit faire pareil ?
Je sais pas. Il faut il faut étudier.
Moi je il y a pas de position commune
tant qu'il y aura pas d'Europe commune.
C'est pour ça qu'il est intéressant
d'avoir des positions communes et donc
d'avoir d'avoir une Europe une Europe
une Europe forte qui puisse parler qui
puisse parler d'une même voie. Toutes
les choses doivent être doivent être les
intérêts allemands sont pas exactement
les intérêts français hein. C'est c'est
bien évident. Même les Allemands nous
empêchent parfois d'aller vendre de
l'armement. On voit bien et c'est pour
ça que pour que l'Europe puisse parler,
il faut qu'elle arrive à se faire pour
que les intérêts les intérêts soient
communs. Et là, vous mettez le doigt sur
quelque chose qui est qui est qui est
important, moi qui me saute à la figure,
c'est que le monde a profondément besoin
d'Europe. Le monde a profondément besoin
d'Europe. Vous
vous présentez aux élections européennes
bientôt ?
Oh, sûrement pas. Non, sûrement pas.
Sûrement pas. Sûrement pas. Le le monde
a profondément besoin d'Europe. Pourquoi
? parce que on est dans un monde
[grognement] le monde de 1945 San
Francisco a disparu. Il il est en train
de disparaître. D'accord ? Et donc tout
tous les instances qui ont été mises en
place de manière intelligente à la fin
de la guerre mondiale sont en train de
disparaître. Le monde n'est plus régulé
et c'est évidemment pas le G8 ou le G20.
Et quand je dis G20 20 ça s'écrit Ven
hein. C'est qui qui sont capables qui
sont capables de réguler le monde. Et
donc on a un monde qui n'est plus
régulé. Les États-Unis se sont retirés
du monde, Obama, Trump encore et donc
l'instance de régulation
ultime qui était aux États-Unis ne
régule plus. Donc on a un monde dérégulé
avec de la montée des tensions, de la
montée des violences. Quel est le
continent enfin arrivé à maturité après
s'être déchiré dans la cour de l'école
pendant des décennies des millénaires ?
C'est l'Europe. L'Europe est un
continent mature qui a tellement
souffert de la guerre qu'il a qu'il a
compris ce que c'était. Et donc je pense
que l'Europe qui est le continent des
lumières de la philosophie, qui est un
qui qui est porteur de la de la de la de
la civilisation, ce continent-là est un
contrepoids naturel à à la montée des
hégémonismes, des volontés d'empire et
cetera. Et donc c'est pour ça que le
monde a besoin d'Europe. Le rôle que les
États-Unis ne sont plus capables de
jouer et ne veulent plus jouer, il est
possible que l'Europe soit capable de
jouer et c'est maintenant qu'il faut le
faire. et le monde a besoin d'Europe
maintenant. Il faut faire l'Europe très
rapidement. Mais encore une fois,
l'Europe n'existera que quand le calibre
de ces canons sera suffisant. Et c'est
pour ça que le problème de la défense
européenne, de l'autonomie défense
européenne est un problème est est une
est à mettre en permanence en relation
avec les problèmes de stabilité du
monde. Euh
une question euh de la communauté euh on
voudrait vous entendre concernant le
budget de l'armée et sa légitimité en
lien avec l'annonce de la grosse hausse
de la part du gouvernement.
Alors, ouais, on va juste parler du
budget de l'armée.
Le budget de l'armée. Le budget de
l'armée.
Et j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi de de
quelque chose qui m'avait marqué à
l'époque, le fameux groupe surcouf. H
alors euh le le parlons parlons parlons
du du budget de l'armée. Enfin enfin
nous sommes revenus à quelque chose qui
n'est pas parfait mais qui devient
raisonnable. pendant 25 ans, depuis
entre 89 et 2018, ça de faire un peu
plus même, nous avons eu des budgets de
déconstruction de l'armée française
parce que l'armée était pour deux
raisons, pour deux raisons. La première,
c'est que nous étions dans l'illusion de
ce que Fabius, président, premier
ministre Fabius ou le ministre Fabius ou
le président Fabius a appelé hein les
dividendes de la paix. la guerre était
morte, on l'avait tué la guerre et donc
on avait plus besoin des armées de ces
gens qui traînaient en kaki dans les
rues et qui ne servaient à rien. Et donc
et bien on et cette idée-là a perduré en
Europe longtemps puisque la la guerre
n'est revenue en Europe que depuis
Daesh, je dirais depuis quelques années
et donc pendant très longtemps, on n'a
pas très bien compris à quoi ça servait
et donc l'armée, on aimait bien parce
qu'elle défile mais on comprend pas très
bien. qu'on peut diminuer diminuer ces
budgets
à partir du moment où la le problème de
la défense n'était plus un problème
citoyen. Ça n'était plus un problème
citoyen puisque le citoyen était plus
menacé. Ce n'était pas un problème
politique. Tout ce qui n'est pas un
problème citoyen n'est pas un problème
politique. Donc c'est pas un problème
politique. Donc je m'en occupe pas. Donc
je prends de l'argent à ceux qui
gueulent jamais. C'est les militaires,
pour prendre à ceux qui gueulent et qui
sont dans les rues. C'est un réflexe
normal si vous voulez. Et donc on a eu
la déconstruction de nos armées avec un
un problème qui est devenu tout à fait
embêtant à partir de du début des années
2000, c'est la montée des guerres. La
montée des guerres qui a commencé par
par l'Afghanistan, ensuite le Sil et
cetera. Et donc, on a eu la une
multiplication des opérations militaires
françaises et donc une inadéquation de
plus en plus importante entre les moyens
donnés aux armées et les missions qu'on
leur demandait. Avec, comme disait le
général de Vidier à à juste titre, la
corde a été tirée jusqu'à cassé. Elle a
cassé quand ? Le 13 juillet 2017 avec
justement la démission du général de
Vidier. Et donc on est rentré dans une
deuxième période où le président Macron
et finalement parce que c un homme
extrêmement intelligent mais qui connaît
pas tout a compris qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose et donc on est lancé on
est rentré dans une autre période qui
s'est concrétisée. Alors revenons un peu
en avant. Le gouvernement ou les
gouvernements Hollande parce que ça
s'est succédé un peu vite vers la fin
hein on ont bien compris que ça pouvait
pas être comme ça. Donc ce grand
mouvement de dégradation c'est un peu
stoppé hein. D'accord mais pas
suffisamment. L'armée française quand
monsieur Hollande l'a l'a quitté était
une armée profondément dégradée.
L'équipe Ledrian Hollande a cassé les
armées françaises, hein. Nous avions
quand ces gens-là ont quitté les
affaires militaires pour monsieur
Ledrillant, moins d'un char sur deux qui
pouvait roller rouler, moins d'un avion
sur deux qui pouvait décoller, moins
d'un bateau sur deux qui pouvaient
prendre la mer, moins d'un hélicoptère
sur trois. Donc on est là. Monsieur euh
le président Macron arrive, prend en
compte cette affaire-là avec un peu de
retard parce qu'il y a eu le 13 juillet
mais prend en compte et on va voir un
certain nombre de choses, une diminution
de la pression sur les armées avec une
réorganisation de l'opération sentinelle
qui va faire qui va diviser à peu près
par trois la pression [grognement] sur
les armées. Un plan famille, on prend
enfin en compte la difficulté des
familles de militaire et puis la
préparation de la loi de programmation
militaire et puis le budget 2018 qui est
qui est en hausse. Donc il faut bien
comprendre que le budget qui est donné
aux armées commence à être un budget de
reconstruction. C'est-à-dire qu'enfin,
on va avoir du carburant pour que les
soldats soldats s'entraînent. On va
enfin avoir des pièces de rechange pour
reconstruire nos bateaux, nos avions,
pour réacheter des chars qui sont des
chars de véhicules blindés dont beaucoup
sont détruits régulièrement au Sahel.
C'est comme ça. Donc il faut arriver à
reconstruire. Donc on va enfin petit à
petit. Et si cet effort continue
effectivement jusqu'en 2025 comme ça a
été annoncé, alors peut-être
retrouverons-nous des armées capables
d'assurer la défense de la France. Mais
ne nous trompons pas, le budget 2018 est
un budget en trompeœuil. C'est-à-dire
que le budget 2018 qui a augmenté
facialement, je crois, de 1,7 milliards,
ce budget-là en fait n'a été fait que
une grosse partie de ce budget en fait a
financé des dépenses qui avaient été
engagées sans financement par euh les
derniers gouvernements euh de monsieur
Hollande. Donc une une grande partie,
presque la moitié, c'est juste du
refinancement. Quant à la 2e moitié, on
voit que très récemment, on vient d'en
voler une partie puisque les armées
françaises euh ne devaiit financer et
c'est bien normal qu'une partie
seulement des opérations extérieures. Le
surcoup des opérations étant pris en
compte, en charge parce que par le
processus appelé de solidarité
interministérielle. Et on vient
d'apprendre que les armées périr
l'ensemble. Ça veut dire que là quel
tout calcul fait alors c'est difficile
parce que chacun dit le tout mais il est
sûr que on vole là à nouveau aux armées
françaises entre 400 et 600 millions. Et
donc ce budget cette augmentation
maintenant on peut estimer qu'au lieu
d'être 1AR7 elle est plutôt peut-être de
3 ou 400 millions, mais pas beaucoup
plus. C'est-à-dire que la remontée qu'on
espérait et bien elle est très
inférieure à ce qu'on souhaitait. Les
armées françaises ont refait confiance à
monsieur Macron. Il y a une période de
défiance après l'affaire du 13 juillet
et puis ce qui a été fait c'était des
signes d'amour, des vrais signes, des
vraies preuves d'amour. Mes premières
encoches graves, cette affaire de
financement des euh des opérations
extérieures et euh et j'espère que ça va
pas continuer comme ça si vous voulez
parce que les armées aujourd'hui elles
sont calmes, elles sont elles sont enfin
elles retrouvent un peu d'air pour
respirer. Enfin les les les familles,
les les parents, les papas, la pression
opérationnelle est moins importante.
Donc les gens reviennent dans leur
famille et cetera. Encore que vous devez
savoir que la durée moyenne en opération
à l'extérieur de leur garnison des
soldats est de 140 jours par an, ce qui
est juste totalement intolérable.
L'armée française continue à être
surployée avec la loi de programmation
militaire telle qu'elle était écrite. On
pouvait espérer remonter sortir la tête
hors de l'eau. Mais si dès le premier
budget on commence à donner des coups de
canif alors je crois que euh les armées
vont perdre cette confiance qu'ils
commençaient à retrouver envers leur
chef.
Et donc s'ils perdent leur confiance,
ils perdent leur calme, il se passe quoi
?
Il se passe quelque chose de grave si
vous voulez, c'est que on doit il est
important dans une dans un pays hein. Le
le soldat il est prêt à aller mourir
s'il faut hein. Le soldat il a donné sa
vie à la nation qui lui prend ou qui lui
prend pas. Mais il est prêt mais il faut
qu'il y ait un lien de confiance
extrêmement fort entre le chef des
armées qui est en France le président de
la République et les armées. Et quand ce
lien de confiance est rompu, et ben
c'est c'est c'est tout à fait tout à
fait dommageable pour pour la défense de
la France. Et puis voilà, ça ça c'est
tout à fait embêtant. Le moral des
troupes qui était bas, qui était
extrêmement bas pendant toute la le
gouvernement toute la présidence
Hollande était en train de remonter.
Quand vous avez pas de moral dans les
armées, ben les soldats, ils se battent
beaucoup moins bien que s'ils ont le
moral. Le moral, c'est le premier
ingrédient de l'efficacité des armées.
Perd de confiance, baisse du moral et
bien perdre de l'efficacité.
Le groupe surcouffe, ça vous parle ?
Rien.
Non, je vois pas trop ce que c'est. Non,
du tout du tout.
Non, je vois pas trop ce que c'est. Non.
De une alliance de gradé qui contestait
un peu l'état.
Alors, moi je crois pas. Non, non. le le
groupe le groupe le groupe surcouf le
groupe surcouf ça a été des des
officiers des officiers et qui à juste
titre qui
de valeurs
de purement de grandes valeurs de
grandes valeurs qui à juste titre avait
senti que la la première loi de
programmation militaire 2008-213
hein qui qui a été préparée par le
gouvernement
par le président Sarkozy était une
première armée de destruction des
armées. N'oublions pas que sous la
présidence Sarkozi, nous avons perçu 25
% de nos capacités militaires et que le
plan de Hollande, c'était encore 25 % et
ça ça a été un peu arrêté par la montée
en puissance de Daesh. Et donc un
certain un certain nombre d'officiers
dans leur sens du bien commun, dans le
sens de l'avenir, on on ont décidé qu'il
était nécessaire d'alerter la France
hein sur ce le plan de destruction des
armées qui avait été concocté. par sous
la présidence Sarkozy et ils ont eu
raison de le faire. Et là là on a une
une grave difficulté en France si vous
voulez quand vous êtes un officier
d'actif, je le sais puisque j'en ai
personnellement subi les conséquences et
que vous prenez en votre âme et
conscience, vous prenez la parole pour
dire voilà ce que je pense sans sans
remonter contre le gouvernement et
cetera, vous êtes immédiatement puni.
qui m'est arrivé. Donc évidemment, si
vous ne pouvez pas dire les choses et
ben vous les dites à Montouvert ou vous
les dites sous le sous le pseudo sous un
pseudonyme que que vous choisissez.
C'est pour ça qu'il est tout à fait
important et moi je j'en ai été un un un
un fervant défenseur et je le suis
toujours. Il est nécessaire que les
militaires retrouvent dans le débat
public la place qu'ils devraient avoir
et qu'ils ont eu parfois en France à la
fin avant la Première Guerre mondiale,
après la deuxième guerre mondiale, on a
une parole libre des militaires sur les
sujets qui les concernaient et on a à la
France leur a retiré. Il y a eu pour un
certain nombre de raisons la le PCH
d'avril 1963
le 3 ou de je j'oublie en Algérie la
dissuation du CL on a eu un certain
nombre de facteurs qui ont fini par
cantonner le militaire dans un rôle qui
est le sien. Mais le rôle le militaire a
un autre rôle. Le militaire n'est pas
uniquement un bretteur, un porteur de
fusil. le militaire qui a le sens du
futur, qui a le sens du long terme parce
qu'une armée ça se prépare dans le long
terme et ça se détruit dans le courme.
Une un militaire a le droit de prendre
la parole dans les dans les conditions
convenables dans sous une forme
convenable pour participer au débat
parce qu'il est le professionnel de
l'armée parce qu'il est le professionnel
de la guerre et qu'il faut écouter les
professionnels quand ils parlent de leur
métier.
Vous parlez d'écoute.
Ce groupe surcouf a été mis sur écoute
par les flics.
C'est normal, c'est pas normal.
Vous savez, les écoutes, il y a une loi
en France hein. Quand vous êtes quand
vous dépassez la loi, c'est anormal. Et
là, je pense hein, soit il y avait une
une prise de décision ministérielle qui
donnait le droit d'écouter, de suivre
les officiers. Alors moi, j'ai été
écouté très longtemps. J'ai été écouté
très longtemps pendant au moins 2 ans.
Bon, je pense pas que jamais aucun
mandat n'ait été donné aux écoute aux
écoutes gouvernementales pour le faire.
Et donc,
vous gardez de la renqueur.
Comment
vous en gardez de la renqueur,
vous savez ? Moi non, je garde pas là en
cœur. Moi je je suis un officier qui est
qui a des opinions qui qui qui les
exprime et et j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
de rancur. Ça m'a fait très mal quand on
m'a amené à quitter l'armée alors que
j'aurais dû rester poursuivre ma
carrière après 38 ans de service hein et
que vous êtes jeté dehors après avoir
servi la France, prête à lui donner sa
votre vie si était nécessaire, qu'on
vous met dehors et que la seule chose
que vous fassiez en quittant c'est
signer la demande de punition que le
ministre a faite pour vous, ça ne peut
pas ne pas vous faire mal au cœur. Et
bien sûr, j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai
souffert. Bon, je suis passé je suis
passé je suis passé au-delà et ce et ça
ne m'a en rien
euh ça n'a rien en rien dégradé la
passion que j'ai pour la France et
l'admiration que j'ai pour les armées
françaises qui sont une institution
absolument remarquable et qu'il faut
préserver parce qu'elles sont évidemment
un atout de la France et un pilier fort
de la de la de la patrie et de
et et des Français. Une petite question
euh pour faire une petite transition,
une petite question gentille sur Sylvie
Goulard. Euh je vais demander à mon tech
impeccable. Parfait. Pour question
d'internet, pourquoi Sylvie Goulard
a-t-elle été réellement viré du poste de
ministère de la défense, de ministre de
la défense ?
Bon, vous sa vous savez bien pourquoi
vous sa vous savez bien pourquoi c'était
pour pour la pour la même raison que
monsieur Berérou a préféré a préféré
partir, c'est qu'on avait des des des
conflits d'intérêt et que il a été jugé
meilleur probablement par madame Goulard
et par le président Macron que que que
ça se passe comme ça. Alors moi je
connais pas je connais pas le détail.
Euh ce ce qui est sûr et on voit bien
dans le cas de de de Carlos Gon, c'est
que quand on exerce des responsabilités
importantes, ben je crois qu'il faut se
présenter de manière irréprochable. Ne
pas donner ne pas donner euh place à la
critique mais critique justifié ou non.
Mais en tout cas, dès qu'on peut
affaiblir le gouvernement, je pense que
alors je sais pas si c'était le cas, moi
je connais pas ce cas particulier, mais
si la présence d'un ministre peut
affaiblir le gouvernement, tu sais que
l'action d'un la la un gouvernement en
France a toujours un peu de mal à
gouverner compte tenu de l'aspect un peu
gaulois de nos de nos de nos chers de
nos chers concitoyens, bah je crois
qu'il est mieux effectivement que le
ministre s'en aille. Que ce soit avéré
ou pas, que ce soit avéré ou pas, on n
pas le droit d'affaiblir un gouvernement
qui cherche à faire le mieux pour la
France.
Euh donc on a eu notre petite
transition. Euh vous parliez de gaulois,
je vais vous parler de gaulois
réfractaire. Les gilets jaunes, si ça
monte fort en puissance pour des
contestations sociales x ou y, que fera
l'armée ? Mais l'armée est à est à est
aux ordres des politiques. L'armée
l'armée ne fera rien. L'armée est aux
hommes des politiques. Ce sera ce sera
pas l'armée qui va décider de sortir de
ces casernes. Ça c'est un c'est un un
schéma intellectuel qui qui existe pas.
Si si le politique dit on envoie l'armée
pour faire ranger les gilets, est-ce que
l'armée prendra le côté de sa population
?
Mais mais
le gouvernement ne le fera pas. Le
gouvernement ne le fera pas. Ce serait
un aveu d'impuissance absolument
considérable. Attendez, heureusement
qu'il y a toute une gradation possible
d'action et le problème, si on en arrive
à régler cette affaire-là par la force
massivement,
c'est qu'on est au bord de la
catastrophe si vous voulez. Il est
évident que le président Macron et son
gouvernement vont trouver les solutions,
vont trouver le moyen de communiquer
correctement parce qu'on est surtout
dans un problème d'incompréhension
mutuelle. Il y a eu des problèmes de
communication, il y a eu un problème
aussi et je pense qu'on arrêtera sur ce
sujet-là compte tenu de l'heure qui
avance. Mais il y a il y a il y a il y a
eu un problème d'attente très fort.
Peut-on en vouloir euh à à à à l'équipe
du président Macron ? Je sais pas mais
c'est vrai que beaucoup a été promu en
certé de cette catastrophique présidence
Hollande et les Français quand même ont
vu un jeune arrivé Sky
was the limite hein. On pouvait monter
on y a cru et tellement d'espoir a été
mis que au bout d'un an un an et demi on
sait bien qu'on peut pas tout faire. Il
aurait fallu tout faire tout de suite.
Ce que dit le président Macron à juste
titre mais c'est difficilement
communicable. Je vous promets que ça va
aller mieux. Je vous promets que dans 5
ans on va arriver. je vous promets et
probablement mais on sait que les
mesures prises par un gouvernement ne
peuvent pas avoir un effet immédiat et
je sais que c'est difficile et c'est
pour ça que on est surtout devant un
problème de communication et peut-être
aussi de communication vraie et puis un
problème de communication factuelle
c'est-à-dire que on n'est pas obligé de
faire des choses qui irritent et qui
sont naturellement mal comprises. Je
pense par exemple au 5 € d'APL, ça
rapporte pas grand-chose mais ça met
tout le monde en colère. les 80 km à
l'heure, est-ce qu'il fallait le faire
maintenant ? Non. ISF
les l'ISF, je [raclement de gorge] je
sais pas. Après, il y a des mesures
économique. Ce qui est sûr, c'est que
une économie ne fonctionne que si
l'argent rentre et pas si l'argent part.
Donc, il faut que les entrepreneurs
entreprennent. Il faut que l'argent soit
investi et donc il faut créer les
conditions de la création d'emplois et
ça ça va par le fait il faut bien que
quelqu'un investit parce que l'économie
libérale est faite comme ça si les gens
ont intérêt à investir ou alors vous
tombez dans le communisme et alors on
sait que ça ne marche pas et ça c'est la
souffrance totale des peuples et la
monté des totalitarismes. Il faut
admettre l'économie libérale comme elle
est avec ses ses avantages, ses
inconvénients mais admettre que et bien
c'est l'intérêt des gens qui vont qui va
faire avancer. Maintenant le problème
c'est les débordements du capitalisme et
peut-être qu'un gon avec son son son
salaire et était la le contrexemple de
ce qu'il fallait faire. Il ne faut pas
que ceux qui sont les premiers
bénéficiaires du capitalisme on
entraînent la perte. Là il y a une vraie
vérité. Le capitalisme qui est la
solution, le libéralisme qui est la
solution ne doivent pas devenir barbare.
C'est bien là la difficulté. Donc il y a
ça à reconstruire. Il va falloir
remettre des limites probablement au
libéralisme débridé. Mais on ne peut pas
faire en sorte, il faut faire en sorte
que les Français aient un intérêt et
envie d'investir pour créer des emplois.
C'est bien ça le problème.
Je vous entends, vous feriez un un très
bon candidat République en marche. Euh
euh
donc on peut envoyer l'armée à la
Réunion pour aller calmer la Réunion.
C'est c'est c'est bon.
Mais mais non, j'ai jamais dit ça. Mais
non, mais non, mais attendez, non ne me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit. Je
d'une part l'armée est aux ordres du
politique et fera ce que le politique
lui demandera de faire. Voilà, les
choses sont claires. Les choses sont
claires. Mais compte tenu le l'armée,
vous savez, il faut il faut être être
précis. L'armée, elle sait faire un
certain nombre de choses. Il y a des
choses qu'elle ne sait pas faire
comme le maintien de l'ordre public.
C'est pas son boulot. C'est pas son
boulot. L'armée, elle est profondément
faite pour agir à l'extérieur du
territoire euh national par la force et
la force létale si nécessaire. C'est son
travail. C'est pour ça que on a créé des
gendarmes mobiles puis des euh des
policiers mobiles hein, les compagnies
républicaines de sécurité pour avoir une
gradation dans l'emploi de la force.
C'est pour ça qu'on a des forces de
trois catégories. Mais quand un état euh
en est à utiliser ou en venait à être
dans l'obligation d'utiliser les forces
de 3è catégorie qui sont les armées, ce
serait qu'on serait au mort de la bord
de la révolution. Quand vous utilisez
les armées, vous êtes obligé de les
utiliser avec leurs armes, d'accord ? Et
que que et les armes militaires, c'est
pas des armes non létales, ce sont des
armes létales. Donc, il faut d'abord
passer par là et donc dire la l'armée,
c'est la solution. Non, l'armée ça n'est
pas la solution et ça n'est pas son
métier.
Euh on on s'approche que vous l'avez
vous l'avez si bien souligné de la fin.
Est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de
la collapsologie ? Je sais pas ce que
c'est ça.
Euh un effondrement de la société
occidentale de par une surconsommation,
un épuisement des ressources,
un effondrement. Est-ce que vous avez
entendu parler de l'effondrement ?
Non, je je sais pas de quoi vous voulez
me parler mais ce ce ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il vous parle.
Ce qui est sûr ce qui est sûr, je suis
ingénieur. Ce qui est sûr
ingénieur qui veut dire
comment
qui veut dire que la cour de gosse, on
l' quand même étudié un tout petit peu.
Concepteur d'armes
hein comment ?
Concepteur d'armes non. ingénieur, ça
veut dire
je suis ingénieur, j'ai un diplôme
d'ingénieur. Je suis docteur en
histoire, je suis ingénieur, j'ai état
de diplôme. Voilà, je suis ingénieur.
Donc la courbe de gauche, oui, je sais
ce que c'est. Et non, ce qui est sûr,
c'est que ce qui est pas tenable, c'est
que la la la planète dépense beaucoup
plus qu'elle ne qu'elle qu'elle ne
produit et que donc ça ça peut pas durer
éternellement et et et qu'on sait bien
soit on trouve un moyen de régulation,
soit on va vers des problèmes graves qui
peuvent être, je sais pas si c'est
l'effondrement, la révolution, le
machin, on va vers des problèmes. Ce qui
est sûr, c'est que il va falloir trouver
une solution. C'est pour ça que
l'écologie, je sais pas si c'est la
bonne solution, les taxes carbone, mais
l'écologie c'est un vrai problème. C'est
un vrai problème et il faut l'adresser.
Le problème, c'est que c'est un problème
de de moyens, voir de long terme. Mais
c'est à nous effectivement hein, comme
disait fort justement euh je ne sais
plus qui d'ailleurs hein, nous nous
empruntons nous empruntons, nous avons
emprunté, je sais pas si c'est lui qui
disait ça, mais on emprunte la terre à
nos à nos à nos à nos à nos enfants. Et
c'est et c'est vrai. Et moi je pense que
ma génération quittera cette bonne terre
à un moment où elle sera toujours
vivable. Quand je vois mes petites
filles,
je sais pas, je sais pas mais je pense
que nous on connaîtra pas ça. Moi vous
vous peut-être et quand je vois mes
petites filles jouer au soleil dans le
jardin du Luxembourg, je me dis que
peut-être que leur génération va être
dans 10 difficultés que nous ne pouvons
même pas imaginer. Voilà, merci beaucoup
de m'avoir reçu.
Euh donc la dernière question, c'est
Ah non non, là il faut que vous me
lâchiez hein.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations
et trois bouquins à conseiller.
[rires]
Un un conseil pour la jeune génération.
Alors, je crois qu'il faut euh
croire en son pays. Je crois que c'est
je crois que c'est fondamental. Croire
en son pays et croire dans le collectif.
L'homme ne se sauvera qu'avec les
autres. Le problème de notre de notre
monde actuel, c'est qu'il est gouverné
par l'égoïsme, que les moyens de
communication moderne moderne ont cassé
les liens ont cassé les liens sociaux et
que la nation française est de moins en
moins une nation parce que chacun vit
d'abord pour lui et que tous les groupes
d'hommes qui faisaient la collectivité,
qui faisaient la force de la nation ont
tendu à à à disparaître, à se dissoudre
dans l'espace. Donc il faut croire aux
besoins de la nation. bien croire que
l'individu ne peut se réaliser que dans
le collectif et pas pour et par
lui-même. Ça ça me paraît absolument
fondamental. Donc aller à 180° des
mouvements euh de l'individualisme
ambiant, des des qui qui est en train de
casser le collectif, croire au collectif
et croire en l'homme parce que les
solutions viennent ne viennent jamais de
la technologie, ils viennent de l'homme.
Croire dans le collectif et croire dans
l'homme, donc croire à l'homme dans le
collectif, ça ça me paraît absolument
absolument fondamental.
Trois bouquins.
Trois trois trois trois bouquins euh
trois bouquins là. Alors, je je
conseillerai naturellement la lecture de
de de mes ouvrages comme j'en ai écrit
une dizaine, hein. On en trouvera on en
trouvera facilement.
Le dernier s'appelle comment ? Le
dernier livre, mon dernier livre
s'appelle La dernière Bataille de France
qui était un ouvrage
qui qui a d'ailleurs eu le Grand Prix,
un grand prix de la de la de l'Académie
française qui a été publié en 2015 et
qui était un combat pour la
reconstruction des armées françaises. Et
le combat que j'ai conduit, ça c'était
une arme de combat avec d'autres à à
porter ces fruits. Et donc je suis
content d'avoir participé à ce combat
par mes différentes interventions dans
les médias et par ce livre qui avec
d'autres a conduit à une espèce à une
prise de conscience française de la
nécessité absolue de euh de reconstruire
les armées. Alors des livres, moi je
c'est difficile d'un dans de de de con
livres, on a énormément de livres. Ce
qui est sûr, c'est c'est que c'est par
la lecture qu'on qu'on arrive à prendre
suffisamment de hauteur pour arriver à
comprendre les les problèmes les
problèmes du monde. la lecture la
lecture d'œuvre intellectuelle hein vont
permettre de se doter des outils qui
vont permettre de de de comprendre les
les véritables sources et les problèmes
et et
les les les solutions les meilleures aux
problèmes gigantesques que nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui.
Mon général, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]